[Music]
are we rolling
what what is that are you timing this
interview
so i know what time it is do you want me
to not is it a no
put it back okay but what what did you
can you just explain to me the
psychology of that
for those of you listening lex just put
his phone on the table
and it had like a stopwatch going
it contextualizes like how we're doing
because if i look down on the phone
and i could tell that time has passed
way faster than it usually passes
that means i'm having fun that's how i
know i'm having fun i'm just kidding
you need proof that you're having fun
yeah i'm like that i don't i
i'm not good at fun because i feel like
when i'm supposed to be having fun
i get in my head too much and
i'm such a perfectionist that i'm like
i'm not having fun well enough
yeah exactly that's what i do like if
i'm at a wedding or something i'm like
i end up just kind of taking pictures of
people and documenting it
because i can cast myself in a role
that's socially acceptable
because i'm not like the get in the
middle dance guy of the cert dance
circle
and having fun for me is exhausting
because i feel like i'm just not doing
it
right yeah that's the problem with like
podcasting because i've been doing
i'm doing my own podcast thank you for
doing it all those months ago by the way
that's right and it's so
hard to just lose yourself in the fun of
the conversation
because like you're too busy judging
yourself yeah like how am i doing
this that was a stupid question that was
a stupid thing i just said
you know you're just constantly judging
yourself but also isn't that what makes
people great of what they do yeah
conscious self-examination
yeah hating yourself is very good for
productivity
the problem is life is short it ends and
you never get to enjoy it
the most um the least talented people i
know are the most confident about their
talent
yeah but you have to like so the way i i
try to do is i oscillate back and forth
i'm full of self-doubt i hate everything
i do but every once in a while
not often during the day i'll just be
like damn it's awesome to be alive
just just like breathe in and out
just realize it be grateful that uh
for everything just for the ability to
breathe ability to
do all the awesome things that i get to
do that all of us get to do
i don't know and nature helps too you
should use that
for what's a good pickup line i'm that's
what this this whole thing
is i thought this was a date
so the first thing i usually ask on this
podcast is are we friends what's our
relationship
are we friends it's just so that the
viewers know have some context
afterwards after what we did last night
with the handcuffs the things you did to
me that was
i thought that was crossing all kinds of
lines because you're i mean i just feel
like i wasn't allowed to make untoward
jokes like that now that you're opening
four minutes in i mean how many minutes
yeah four minutes ten seconds in you're
already doing handcuff jokes this is
gonna go off the rails
yeah i was trying to be respectful
because you're a you know
assigned allegedly scientist yeah you're
a professional scientist
yeah no yeah i think so i think you're
what are we to each other
what do i mean to you i i thought we
were dating for the last few months but
i guess
why because we haven't spoken in four
minutes yeah
i thought you were just playing hard to
get
why is she not responding to all the
phone calls i did have this theory the
other day
that i was thinking about how it's so
much harder to play
hard to get now or to give men the
silent treatment or any of our
sort of like tactics i'm not saying
they're healthy i'm just
we use them we do uh because women
are now in the workforce and they're
successful and i think i come off to
people is very busy
so sometimes when i'm trying to play
hard to get with a guy
it backfires because he's like well i
just figured you were busy you're so
busy i'm like no i'm trying to give you
the silent treatment
i'm trying to ignore you yeah like i
can't do it anymore because i'm too busy
i've lost those tools of manipulation
i thought you were going somewhere else
with this like instagram like if you
keep posting on instagram
then it makes it difficult to say that
like
because you what's hard to get you want
to actually show that you are busy
that you have a life outside of you like
outside the other person right not sure
if guys like that though
i think i think
yeah i know for sure i'm like everyone's
different but i i like it
when all that bullshit is thrown aside
when you like just start texting
when you send like 100 texts i admire
that like
wait hold on text yeah like when you're
just crazy a little bit
because we're all crazy we all every
once in a while are crazy
if you allow yourself to be lost in the
infatuation of somebody else
i don't know so you're saying if a girl
texts you a hundred times you're into it
depends the content of the text if
they're all just
titty photos 100 tits is fine a hundred
a hundreds what are you thinking not
fine no if it's like if like 90 percent
of it is like
angry at why are you not responding then
it's not fine
but if it's like running if it's like
tweet quality
thoughtful like like funny i would never
waste a
good tweet on a guy i would tweet it
yeah
that's true uh no i mean i'm joking of
course about the hundred but like
i feel like being lost
in uh just liking somebody and not
giving a damn about the game
the rules of how it's supposed to work
that's kind of cool that's the new cool
thing i think i also think that we
grossly overestimate sort of the power
of those if you like someone them
texting you three times in a row
is endearing if you don't they're a
stalker you know
it's like the he leaves the cap off the
toothpaste if i
don't like him it's annoying if i like
him it's like oh i can't stay mad at you
you silly gives you leave the cap off
the toothpaste
it's like yep you know confirmation bias
or
or whatever if you like the things that
annoy you about people i don't think
they
would annoy you if you actually really
liked them that's a good test for me
with people is like if i
see something about another person and
it annoys me
that means it's not going to work a
hundred percent
like i'm was texting with this guy the
other day and i was like am i coming out
too strong am i being too aggressive and
i'm like
if this text makes or breaks it he
doesn't like me
he's not into me like if i can't just be
authentic like i c
and i also i'm just at a place where i i
don't want to
curate my interactions too much or
script them or overthink them because it
ultimately just boils
you're just lying and pretending yeah
it's just gross you're just being gross
can't criticize you about something
i'm coming in strong hot coming in very
high
i forgot the podcast you said this on so
i'm also a fan of your podcast
you said uh you're talking about some
older gentleman you used to date
and then he would pl that old that this
was your criticism about quote-unquote
old dudes that
yeah that they he played uh bruce
springsteen's i'm on fire hey little
girl is your daddy home
did he go and leave you all alone
did you just fall in love with me i did
it
but that's an awesome song because i was
actually
unless you're a little girl and your
daddy's not home well
in which case it's a creepy song well
love is creepy
so correct agree tweet that
i shouldn't have said this on this
podcast okay give me tweet it
what's the criticism that that's an
awesome song and it's ridiculous
criticism
bruce springsteen is one of the greatest
musical artists of all time
i agree and then you just kind of you
kind of threw
you used i just criticized you for just
throwing bruce springsteen under the bus
i didn't throw him under the
bus almost canceled there's this new
thing there's this new thing where
if a woman just acknowledges a creepy
thing that a guy did she threw him
under the bus it's like springsteen i
know
it's bruce springsteen first of all i
don't think i have the power to cancel
bruce springsteen okay
i just like to what i like to call fresh
eyes
i like to look at things with fresh eyes
and go remember when we thought that was
normal
and you look back and you're like oh
that was kind of creepy as someone
that appreciates creepy behavior has
participated in creepy behavior and
frankly
likes older guys and i i just like to
look back no that was so weird that we
used to just sing that
in the car okay i got it what's your
i liked i i love older the best thing
about older guys
for me now is that when you hang out
with them you get to accidentally
listen to r kelly because they didn't
hear
they don't know what kind of older guys
are here
hanging out with r kelly yeah like
yeah ever yahoo news or whatever they
get wherever they get their news didn't
cover the r kelly scandal so like
ignition will come on every now and then
ironic though i mean r kelly made some
bops and if you want to hear his music
uh and not get cancelled you have to
date older guys
okay you have to be like turn that off
turn it off
turn it off wow i'm regretting this uh
podcast
wait so here i have a couple
i'm really sort of paralyzed on how to
start this conversation with you i
thought we already started
oh my god literal guy are you that guy
in fights with women you're like i
didn't say you were a bitch i said you
were
acting like a bitch your literal guy no
not little guy
really no i don't need to win you win
if i win we both lose no
i'm that person oh well i'm not fighting
against you i'm fighting
well you're a people pleaser so not so
much anymore
no you keep saying that you still are
you think
you're like you're trying to fake it
until you make it yeah we're just doing
sex now what are we talking about
yeah we're back to last night so let me
ask you a question do you feel like
you always saying you're single like
what are you doing with that what is
that
what is this rigmarole saying you
actually want a girlfriend do you
actually want to solve this problem yeah
100 so what's
because i have a theory that if you
wanted a girlfriend you'd have one
that's a yeah that's an interesting
theory so first of all
that's his way of saying fuck you
yeah so i think
i think a relationship is one of the
most fulfilling things you can have like
family too like
i'd love to have kids i'm not obsessed
with it but
that seems to be like i mean you build
robots it's the same thing yeah well
right i know you're kind of joking but
also
kind of not yeah there's there's
something
deeply fulfilling also about building
cool shit like
just bringing your ideas to life but you
can't program a kid
that's that's the thing that's kind of
fascinating i think about having
children is someone that can control
everything and build things custom and
and
uh build how they think and how they
feel and how they move and then you have
a kid and there's just
you can't well that's no control that's
the magical thing about it
is i i was referring to the the magical
part about this whole thing about robots
about kids
is the act of creation and then the rest
is just up to the the
the beautiful way that this world
unrolls like you can't control any of it
really
so like that's fun to me would you say
you're a control freak no
i couldn't it's complicated i
would there's certain things i'm really
ocd about
like maybe arranging like items on a
desk that kind of stuff
but i'm also conscious of it
in um in in i'm conscious of the fact
that if you want to truly enjoy life
you want to just lose yourself in it so
i really enjoy people
that you kind of i think we were talking
off mike about
that people who don't have a schedule
people that just throw it all to the
window but do you
not have as much you have more respect
for those people or less respect
i enjoy being it's not a respect thing i
enjoy having them in my life
but i'm a very much a guy who just sits
down
for two hours four hours 10 hours
whatever it is and i'm just
focused so how is the girlfriend going
to fit into this how is it certainly
if i may do you want an equal oh 100
percent
that's the question because no equal of
yours is going to come in and go yeah
i'm going to
i'll get you for 20 minutes between your
10 hours of coding and two hours of
push-ups and seven hours of david
goggins running or whatever the hell you
do
the way david goggins relationship i
don't know if they're married but it's
awesome
oh cool they found uh you know
they found see equal is a funny word it
is
you are a literal guy no because like uh
you know what does equal mean doesn't
mean both have a career
like to me what a successful
relationship looks like
that's not successful for me what i look
for
is somebody who's really passionate
about what they do
and i can just enjoy cheering them on
in like whatever the hell it is they
love doing like just get like
i they're a nazi yeah well
within real okay you could both which is
kind of weird because i'm jewish so
[Laughter]
the sex would be great
be a little suffocating maybe i could
appreciate it
you went wow i'm sorry timing is good
uh yeah no maybe there's
i'm trying to not be with you i'm sorry
i'm trying to be serious no no no
please i have so much respect for you
and i admire you so much i'm going to
try to not be silly
likewise i'm trying not to compliment
you too much
why not why
because then it'll be just like i mean
you know
you're also there's there's different
kinds of compliments i'm just like a fan
it's a weird experience when you listen
to somebody on a podcast
i already thought we're friends you know
for a long time
before we even you know so you're a
stalker yeah you're the i'm the stalker
i do have a theory that someone that
accuses someone else of something
is that thing yeah exactly whenever
you're in a relationship and someone's
accusing you of cheating you're like
you're cheating
yeah good to know that does apply yes
that's kind of yes
because like why did your brain go there
yeah your brain is obviously already in
that space
so for two like to me relationship wise
for two busy people
what seems to work in my view is if
you're both really passionate about
something and you both draw a lot of
pleasure from
enjoying like cheering each other on and
enjoying the success of each other
in whatever you're passionate about yeah
and you almost like both get into that
thing so
but do you ever want get have you ever
been with someone who's really busy and
drives a lot of pleasure
out of what they do and you feel
competitive with it
or the other thing no i mean that's like
i was talking to gabby reese the other
day um
and she was like look the ocean is
laird's girlfriend
and i'm like go be with your girlfriend
like she has a she's very
you know she understands how important
that is to him and how they're almost in
like a polyamorous relationship with the
ocean
but i definitely
you know want someone that has such a
full life
but there are times where i'm like well
i want to make you feel like that
oh yeah 100 percent i think the success
it's not about the time because you kind
of said like how much time you give them
but when you're in it whatever it is 30
minutes or
hours together you make them feel like
they're the most important
thing in the world i mean absolutely
like family has to be number one
but what is your i'm sure you've not
wasted your precious time
taking silly tests like this but do you
know what your like love language is
like how you get how you give and
receive love
so i'm a leo
[Laughter]
now let's get to the hard science
i don't know what the hell you're
talking i just mean like i mean like how
do you
you know the love languages are based on
like service
physical touch positive affirmations and
gifts
so it's like you know how do you
because there are times where i'll be
dating somebody and i like won't hear
from them for two days but then they'll
show up with like gifts so it's like oh
you've been thinking about me this whole
time but we haven't been contiguous like
we haven't been
actually connecting but
that's just how you show your love is
more through gifts and through service
instead of through
physical presence and touch no i yeah
physical presence and touch like looking
at them
there's something about just presence
like listening you know but could you be
together because you're such a
like a mental performance person like
could you live with someone
and be around them and just co-exist or
would it
you feel like it would be depleting your
focus and draining you
that's the big problem it's difficult
like it that this is where
a girl really for me would help woman is
oh okay i've had that meeting with the
hr
one of the reasons i stepped down from
mit hey little girl is your daddy
we don't call them girls anymore i'm
fine call me a
call me a guy the thing i dislike the
most is a young lady
young lady i prefer girl to young lady
because young lady is like you're
qualifying it with like a
young lady so how does wap fit into all
that
just intellectually just we're all just
okay never not whopping over here
just when you start talking about robots
wop will happen
okay yeah this is going great how am i
performing performance wise
are you judging yourself right now yeah
and one's attacking how are you doing
how do you think you're doing um i think
i can i think i can do better i think
i'm like a four
what yeah but this is good i want the
people to develop
ai and self-driving cars to grade
themselves harshly
so i don't want to change this four is
harsh
i think you're doing way better than
that but you don't and that's fine don't
fix that about yourself
okay keep your self-esteem super low in
your talent that's how you're high
yes well that's how that's how i want my
my
ai engineers to be yeah i want you to be
really hard on yourself not too
confident
i don't want somebody that's like yeah i
don't want someone developing
self-driving cars it's like fucking
nailed it when they sucked
i want you to nail it and be like i
could have done better this is perfect
this is why you're going to have
billions of dollars yeah but uh
i'm going to beg you for your sperm in a
couple years well i am worried
how power and money changes people so i
know what i don't know why
because you have to anticipate but
that's that's just not do you
yeah no but you're gonna have it
regardless i hate money like i've
recently i had no money and now i have
way too much money that's such a guy
thing
that's such a guy thing because i think
for me like i
having says the princess in the castle
which i want to talk about what is your
thing with my house
why is gates why why do guys not like
gates
i've dated a couple guys that are like
why do you have gates into your house
like because people want to kill me
like there was the dragon had to fight
there's this whole i have to protect
myself on a curvy road
up uh up uh but i also have an iud and i
have to
i have to protect myself from certain
things that are trying to get to me
is that like a weapon of some kind an
iud yeah you don't know what iud is i
heard it on a clip that you post on
instagram but i didn't look into it you
don't know what an iud is i do not know
how you do what is your official job
title
scientist
i actually you should call yourself a
feminist scientist
yeah all scientists i feel like are
inherently feminist even though biology
is sexist
oh cancel biology well we'll get to that
in a second okay um
an iud is something that you put in your
uterus to
it's birth control okay
device oh i mean it's not like a chip
it's like a
string with um a
little piece of plastic it's like a
little tiny so there's no electronics
it's like a little um
toy that you get in a cracker jack box
basically with hormones and stuff
mcdonald's yeah it's a mcdonald's toy
but it's uh
uh yeah it's to not so when is the last
time you dated a woman this is really
alarming that you don't know what an ied
is
it hasn't it's been a long time it's
been a dry spell when's the last time
you had a girlfriend
five years ago mm-hmm how long was that
did that and that was
and i haven't had a non-girlfriend after
meeting like
you know just sleeping around or
whatever because i'm i'm excited to talk
to you about
this because i feel like whenever you go
on joe rogan you guys don't talk about
love and relationships yeah this is this
is why you guys come to this podcast
this is what we do
i don't give a shit about robots let's
talk about
love language your personal life love
language
uh i think is i feel like we were
talking about we took a million tangents
well no but i'm just saying that's what
a podcast is i feel like how is it
i'm just saying i feel like the kind of
woman you want is gonna feel slightly
abandoned
by how busy you are and how
hyper-focused you are
like you don't yeah that's a good point
but i feel like the
kind of woman
that i i would i think would work is
somebody who can make fun of me
and and say that i'm being ridiculous
for the way i'm being so like
that's where an equal is really
important because like
you have to be confident enough to uh
show to me that
i'm being ridiculous by being so
obsessed so focused so like
and basically help me break out of that
and here's what i'll say about that
that's fascinating
but i think also as someone excuse me
getting emotional who i know sorry i'm
getting choked up
um as somebody who that's my iud coming
up
as someone who likes to make fun of
people and is playful and facetious
i also think you have to watch
when you're giving your man shit or
making fun of them that you're not
crossing the line into being
disrespectful
it took me a long time to learn this
don't do it in front of people
right don't do it in front of other
people don't do in front of his friends
so i think this is important i think
this is really important
that's one thing you learn from like
donald trump and
his his wife it's like the the image you
never touch your husband is it going the
image you present to the public is
different than like how
i feel like the private relationship is
a different thing than the public
relationship
like that it's uh it's like an iceberg
you can do a lot more in private mm-hmm
yeah i don't know much about either of
their relationships i don't want to
drag that yeah i don't know you're
eastern european you tell me what the
mail order bride process is like i don't
know
you tell me but they're in general i
just had a long conversation with trump
supporter that's why i brought that up
because they were they were suggesting
that it's likely that that
donald trump and melania have like a
vibrant relationship that just the world
doesn't see
interesting and it just opened my eyes
to think like
oh yeah that could be i mean it's also
i'm sure you get into a
almost like stockholm syndrome us
against the world thing i mean that kind
of situation must bond you in a way
that's like a sid and nancy type
thing or a war of the roses type thing
you know we
look at relationships it's taking me so
long to realize like what other people
want
doesn't have to be what i want like when
you talk to your friends you're like oh
and then you fucking won't text me back
and then
she's so crazy and then she screams at
me and you're like well let me help you
get out of that for three hours every
day i'm gonna talk to you on the phone
and give you advice on how to
extricate yourself from this and i'm
like wait no you want that yeah
you want something fucked up and crazy
and dramatic and
shit i kept thinking you were trying to
solve this problem would you love it
that was the other requirement for me
that requirement something i look for
is like that we're like ride or die
against the world
together you want that you want a
teammate yeah did you watch um
uh what was the kevin spacey show house
of cards you want your claire underwood
yeah that was i felt like that was a
healthy relationship i think so too
that's what i want
yeah i always say like if you don't want
to clear underwood don't swipe right
are you on dating apps no no so you want
a girlfriend but you're not doing
anything to try to procure one
no see and when someone does dm you
they're a stalker
yeah i did i did you see why this is a
little bit difficult
yeah well yeah the the i'm not sure
exactly what the right mechanism for
just meeting
people are the i you know one mechanism
is going on podcasts
you will get so many i do you will get a
lot of dms from a lot of girls after
this
i don't know what to do with it though
because like what happens let's say okay
let's say a girl that you're physically
attracted to
dms you you go to her page
and then she's uh she's out of the way
yoga instructor i don't know i feel like
you want like a yoga instructor
who works like two days a week yeah it's
tough like what do i do
because like you know uh i guess um how
did you meet your last girlfriend
uh like the the yellow pages
the old-fashioned way which is what
i had a mutual friend and just arranged
marriage okay
so someone set you up i actually well no
i asked
it was a chance meeting and then i said
i like her but you don't put yourself in
situations to where you can have chance
meetings because you're so regimented in
your life
yeah that's a problem you're not
available you don't make space for it
but i'm hoping i'm hoping that changes
like
i'm hoping because i've been so focused
on you know like
working towards creating the business i
thought
once it gets going like i'll get a
chance to meet with with people like
investors and all that kind of stuff and
you know therefore there's parties
like give myself an excuse to have to go
to a party
would you want to date you no
but that's an interesting question would
would you want to date you
yes fuck yes
dude i'm a blast are you yes how are you
i wouldn't want it fucking awesome
amazing um i feel like you don't believe
that but okay
i do you honestly wow do i think i'm
going to bed
no like the entirety of it but in bed
too i
here's the thing i wouldn't want to take
a scale of one today i wouldn't want to
i wouldn't want to date me uh
five years ago three years ago and
before
i wouldn't want to date me like
seriously uh
but in the last couple of years yeah no
i got no i got dope
what was the hardest thing about dating
you three three years ago
well i have um
i was so obsessed with
i'm just gonna say recreating my
childhood circumstances with my dad
before my dad died
i think my i was so in love with him
like i was so obsessed with getting his
approval and i was so
uh all my neural pathways were so
um crystallized into
just his attention and
i had i was so triggered by anything
that reminded me of him and i was so
attracted to people
that recreated the neurochemical
cocktail that he created
you know i just i just was dating him
him him so if i was dating you before he
died i was only dating you
because you reminded me of him yeah or
made me feel like the way he made me
feel
and then once he died i did some
ayahuasca
thank you joe rogan for the
recommendation and i did a lot of
work around it and it sort of released
that pattern seeking
you know because we're all just kind of
trying to recognize patterns right
so i think before the if before a couple
years ago if i was dating you it had
nothing to do with you
so now if i'm dating you i actually like
you and it's um
and i'm i'm i'm very direct now i'm very
upfront and i'm very
clear and you always know where you
stand
and i finally know how to have an orgasm
oh we're learning so many new things i'm
just saying like i
it you know it takes a minute for you to
find out who you are and what you want
and i'm financially solvent
i need nothing from you which i know not
a lot of guys are attracted to that can
borrow some money yes you can how much
you need
how much do you need why to order a
bride uber ride back
you miss your dad every day all the time
i'll cry if i talk about it too man i'm
obsessed with him i mean it was like
you know i it just took me a really long
time
i wish i had forgiven him sooner i wish
i had known more about
neurology sooner and psychology sooner
to know that the way that he was
he had
become that honestly like he inherited
the ancestral trauma he inherited
the emotional tools that he had his dad
was in a war
um i wish i i wish i had
not blamed him for so much i just said
yeah i just wish i had forgiven him
sooner
what was your favorite part about him um
you're gonna make me cry lex
um he was so funny
the funniest is your dad alive
yeah dad's alive what must be nice
i talk to him often he's good i actually
did a pod i i did a conversation with
him
oh it was very difficult very good why
haven't i heard that one
i'm fully now crying god damn it lex
god damn it okay i'll i'll talk more in
a second when i know that i'm not going
to cry
about it yeah it was weird to sit across
listen it's different than you and your
dad i mean maybe maybe you can correct
me but
there's an ego there's a male thing
where
i'm mad at him for many things he he
wasn't a great dad to me
why would any dads be great until now
what with what tools with what books
with what podcasts that's true there
wasn't rogan wasn't around
like like psychology wasn't around like
there's why would
any dad you know like there was no male
role model to look to that had daughters
it was like i fucking love my daughters
are awesome like
this is the idea of being a good father
i feel like or parent in general like i
feel like
everyone should be grandfathered in
until like
10 years ago yeah i mean that's the
thing with parents
you should give them a pass and we had
child labor within the last 100 years
yeah 14 year olds would just work in
factories and get their fingers cut off
i mean it's just
recently that we treat children with any
kind of respect
so so definitely you're right but still
we're still just apes and i was sitting
across from them and i don't
especially in the podcast like the way i
usually talk to people is
i want i make them the star of the show
and it's really difficult for me
to to make my dad to get because he has
an ego
like to let his ego shine was very
different how would he
where would he have learned to dismantle
his ego and then don't you you're giving
him a pass
don't you think his ego served him
really well yeah for sure
but so why would he put that weapon down
a good man should be able to uh
keep his ego in check but that takes
work you say it it's like saying a good
man should be able to like lift 500
pounds well you have to train for that
well there's things i admire
in a man
like uh being able to be humble
and like self-aware about their
ridiculousness and to be able to keep it
in check
whether it's ego whether whatever the
quirks are but ego definitely
like i if you're intel if you're an
intelligent man which my dad
is i feel like you don't want to flaunt
it
and he flaunts it the other thing but
yeah sorry interrupting cause what i'm
just
i'm just saying like like in his day you
had to flaunt it there was no social
media
how else would people know
it's interesting but you're like we're
we're not
we are in different times now but what
makes a great man
is the same thing still like you should
you shouldn't have ever flaunted it
but peacocking why in every species the
males are
more for women yeah when you i'm sure
listen he's a smooth motherfucker
so like i'm sure he tricked my mom into
like
you know like with the smooth talk
because he actually the university he
went to
like i'm impressed because it was
like less than certainly less than five
percent but it's like close to one
percent were women
so like it was like an mit type of so
this is about two years ago
two years ago yeah this morning this
morning
the so he was he was smooth and solid
and that's great that's beautiful he's a
smooth talker
i love him that's why i enjoy talking to
him is fun which is good why does that
have to be pejorative
i'm i'm another man with an ego and it's
tough to sit in front of your dad
and to say that he to just to tell him
that he
he was uh a great person to sh
and to give him my platform to uh for
his ego to shine
you know i have had probably over a
thousand people now
i've got a lot of people write to me
about that episode
they they write to me that i'm lucky to
have a dad like that he's such a great
person
like i knew that was coming and
because the way i wasn't going to talk
shitty about him on that conversation so
i wanted him to shine
it was tough i'm just being honest but
the way i approached it the reason i did
it
is i was thinking when he passes away
you know 20 years from now
would i be glad that i did this
conversation
and if the answer is yes then yes and
i i was thinking about this way like
when i'm an old man myself like looking
back at that
you know i'll miss the guy he was
incredible human
but in the moment he was so damn cocky
what did you
well he's also not a public figure he's
going on a podcast
he doesn't know he's probably doing an
impression of what he thinks he's
supposed to be doing most people no no
he's ready
he doesn't go on podcasts all that but
he checks the number of views his video
gets
why wouldn't he regularly well he also
raised you
he's obviously smart i know he had you
do you think he did a bad job uh well
i'll be different
i'll be different i think he's also was
afraid to show
em like this is where you're gonna say
yeah everybody back in the day he also
looks like albert einstein yeah he's
legit
i mean so i mean i'd have an ego too if
i looked if people
thought conflated me with albert
einstein all the time
yeah he's that's actually what he does
what what do you do you want that he
didn't give you
i don't want to criticize him too much
but because i would imagine any
shortcomings he's had or things that he
didn't give you
you were able to develop the maladaptive
behaviors that made you great okay my
childhood was perfect
because it was it was it was perfect in
that it wasn't perfect
but it wasn't traumatic enough to
actually do having a perfect childhood
sounds like a nightmare you're not
prepared for real life
the most uh um disappointing people i
know had great challenges exactly i'm
just saying they're not prepared for
real life they can't handle conflict
they can't handle adversity
they can't handle curveballs it's just
like um
i think adversity is good
i'm one of those bullying is good people
yeah which makes you wonder about like
how to be a good parent yeah he did yes
it does give me
any attention so he's very distant
which has a very nice feature that it
makes you want to earn their attention
therefore you work hard like i'm always
seeking his approval
great me too so that's a that's a nice
feature i'm not sure what to do with
that
the so he gave you your engine to come
start a business that's going to make
you a billionaire
fuck you dad no i i i told that part to
him that he that's a gift
uh there you know there's parts like i'm
a total bro
in a sense like i may not look like it
but i'm
i'm very i have like a rogan inside me
and my dad like i really am a man's
man except for the times in like harvard
square and
academia rubs off on me but for the most
part
man's man what does a man's man mean may
i get a
dealer uh
there's just a list of stupid shit you
do like i like lifting heavy things
i like building stuff i i like
i like i love the idea of hunting i love
fishing
i like knives and guns and risk
danger risk and danger yeah okay so i'd
like the carnal sort of
i love fighting combat violence
but not in relationships that's the
thing
back to the last night yep well i'm just
saying it fascinates me that the
guys that want to fight the most
physically have no tolerance for
emotional sparring in relationships like
fuck this bitch is dramatic it's like
you just did jiu jitsu for five hours
and we can't have a
work this out i love i love fighting and
like
like uh play like play fighting
no it's not not it's not i would say
it's the dance of uh
human connection right the tension the
push and pull all that kind of stuff is
different
that's not what i'm referring to when
i'm referring to fighting i mean like
literally getting the streets
right just like just two two monkeys
going at it yeah
i just i don't know i love it the
adrenaline the adrenaline just
well the i'm an alpha you know like i'm
i'm i'm a better motherfucker than you
yeah you embrace that i don't know why i
love that yeah but
i think it's probably a little bit of
nature a little bit of nurture a little
bit of russia
yeah a little bit yeah thank you for for
the listeners
i was born in the soviet union but my
dad was told he was afraid of all of
that he was a
i'm allergic to the word nerd a little
bit because he was
very much a nerd so let me ask you is it
there's i was talking to someone
recently
i think we were like texting off of a
dating app i'm so bad on dating apps
because i just
which dating this is like this
this is like yeah you do it's the
elitist it's like the elitist celebrity
one it's like the
it's such it's just like a bunch of guys
in v-necks with man buns
holding french bulldogs that don't
belong to them it's a disaster
it's i mean you've had success on apps i
met someone who was engaged to someone
off of raya an amazing person
last time we talked was you were engaged
was i yeah oh
i was playing hard to get um
i don't think i was because i looked
back at our interview and i was not
wearing an engagement ring
um yeah no i think that the dating app
thing is like
there's this and i might look i built my
house making fun of dating apps
but it's how is it any less weird than
meeting someone in person
i actually think it's um better
my new thing is and especially someone
that works in ai i'm curious what you
think
everyone's like well this is the end of
it you can't have a real connection with
someone i disagree i totally
think there's so much intimacy in being
able to text with somebody seeing how
they use words
seeing how they use punctuation then
facet my new thing is before date and
person i like to face time
oh interesting i like you because number
for a couple reasons number one
i get to see your house without having
to go back to your house and being a
whore
i get to sort of like see what i'm
dealing with not because i want it to be
big or fancy i just like to
see what kind of person you are i
especially want to know what kind of um
what color your
hand towels are which color are yours
the handle
hand house oh yeah see hand towels
black handhelds can't do it oh hand
towels hand towels
yeah okay white towels are the only
option for me
i got a what what is this
an irreconcilable difference how do you
get out of a bad date by the way
what's the escape clause on on facetime
is the best
my wi-fi my phone died like it's about i
had i had a really bad i had a really
bad facetime date the other night
it was like we were texting off of raya
and he's like let's just facetime i'm
like great
and like fuck it let's go for it let's
just do it and he was
wasted it was awful it was really
embarrassing
yeah but it saved me it saved me going
to see him in person and
see but here's the let me play devil's
advocate please this is the choice
that the app provides like the easy
escape
because like i'm stuck here right now
doing this podcast
so like i'm fully engaged and
you know i won't see another female
of the species for like a long time
right so like why not
it doesn't matter the point the point is
that the the lack of choice
like it really forces you to really
appreciate this moment
i don't know there's something about
apps where you're like shopping that
doesn't
well yes no i mean it really is and i
think it gives you an exaggerated sense
of what's available
you know like it it i think less people
are committing now because there's like
well
what else is out there there's always a
you're always looking for the upgrade
right it's always like but what if i
can't settle for this person because
there's
so many other people out there but
they're actually not available to you
you know but i think it's it's sort of
like becomes like a gambling addiction a
little bit like you
i feel like you have to legitimately
fully consider
that this is the person i'm gonna spend
the rest of my life with
and like live with that thought
like as you're doing the first date are
you just so
such a perfectionist about what you want
to commit to that
that's what sort of stops you from oh
yeah
oh so yeah maybe we disagree on this but
i think like dating a lot of people it's
not my thing
yeah i'm either yeah but like and i
actually believe that
i don't know my own psychology we're all
different but my own psychology is
if i i date a lot of people it's going
to
make me less capable of finding the
right person for me interesting
because i i like to just
not not date unless it's someone that i
think is like exceptional but then i was
like i feel like i have to get my
reps in i feel like it's all practice
like i have to practice or see what i
don't want in order to know what i do
want or i have to just like
experiment i just feel like the person
that you do want
will be the quiet person in the corner
that you won't glance at
because the stalker you could stalk her
in the corner just watching you
because you're getting your reps in you
know like
i don't know i have this you know
because
we've talked off mike about like fasting
and so on
you know how delicious anything tastes
after you fast for like
48 hours it's like the most delicious
thing
and i can marry that thing
so you like to deprive yourself so that
you do indulge its maximum pleasure
i don't know if i like i'm just giving
you a philosophical fact
that uh when you have scarcity you enjoy
it more and i think
you really give you the experience it's
not like
the experience for people who fasted
know this if you haven't fasted i
recommend trying it because
it literally when you eat the experience
is
more fulfilling than any other
experience you've had with food in a
long time
like that's a really important thing
like what life is about those
experiences like
okay so what's the relationship
relationship is
becomes deeper and deeper with the it's
not like the day-to-day thing
it's the few moments you have together
that are magical
in the positive sense and then also a
few moments of like trauma that you
overcome together
i feel like that's where the bond grows
stronger it's not about like optimizing
the day-to-day
it's about going through some shit
together and going through
some amazing experiences together like
those memories
that's why it's easier i think if you if
you get into a relationship and like
when you're super young then you form a
lot of those memories before you know
what the hell you're doing that's right
and then those memories are a beautiful
thing that you share together
which so when you're in your 30s or 40s
sucks it's tougher i'm really
um debating whether i should say this
but the fasting thing how long have you
how long
have you done this
i feel like you're judging with i'm not
judging i'm not judging we're just
[Laughter]
how long have you done this yeah well no
it's just i think that the sip of this
sugar-free
red bull that's the only thing he's
eating today well no i think that the
fasting thing
i'm not not i know there's
you know science to back up why it works
etcetera but
i think women have such a different
relationship with food on
average not generalizing it's like i had
eating disorders like i fast i was
anorexic like
i fasted for 15 years like i wasn't like
a mental performance athlete i just like
hated myself you know so i think
fasting is like i think women have a
slightly different relationship to food
and a more combative relationship with
our bodies
in terms of making it smaller men always
want to make their bodies bigger
women always want to make their bodies
smaller so it's like fasting i feel like
it's a little bit dicey for people that
have have
uh body dysmorphia or like eating issues
not me by the way i'm with brendan shaw
i i naturally get like like
really strong and thick and i like being
lean
so brendan trump's not lean i know but
he likes being lean too oh
i could you don't even know your friends
is trauma
no i don't i don't listen to brendon
when he talks
saying to me again wait he is oh because
when he was fighting
no just in general he's he's a total
well well i'm
very different from him but he's like
into fashion and stuff so he
is he he wants has he ever worn
something fashionable i haven't seen it
is that what you call that fashion well
you like he dressed as like a janitor in
a broadway play
yeah but like i think he's the type of
guy who enjoys like skinny jeans that
kind of thing
but do you have to be skinny to wear
skinny jeans i'm sorry
you don't if you want to look good in
them i suppose you do
i mean i think it hasn't stopped guys
from trying i there's something
interesting i mean you guys are so
different because i think
him coming from professional sports like
everything was so regimented and he had
to wear this and do this and eat this
and
ice and he and then i think now he's
like
just sort of celebrating the fact that
he has some freedom it seems like you
don't want freedom
down to the way you dress none of the
way you schedule yourself down to the
way you eat
like you want to be very regimented is
that just because you know yourself so
well and you know that that's how you
are optimal no no i or you would just
exactly masturbate
freedom i love freedom it's just that i
have a dream i have several dreams
and they they bring me joy and i want to
accomplish them i want to get that one
and you know what it takes in order to
accomplish them
i'm sacrificing a lot because what i
want to do is i want to
this okay like i said i want i want a
relationship
i want to hang out with that person i
want to travel with them i want to do
all kinds of drugs experience everything
just have
fun right that took a weird turn the
thing is
i there's other passions i have that are
even bigger like which
is i want to put a robot in every home i
want to to do a companion robot or
a uh it's a complicated story but
i i would say ai systems that understand
you well
so it's not necessarily just companion
it's also a thing that represents you to
the world
so like a little companion not just in
physical space but in cyberspace
so and coupled to that is
i want to okay one way to put is i want
to bring more love to the world
and i do believe ai systems can help
that and one of the
ways it can help is to improve social
networks
so i'm not sure yet but i think i want
to build the competitor to twitter
interesting so i and i think it's
intricately connected
so building ai systems that are in the
home is connected to
ai systems that connect us to other
human beings in digital space
so and i think communication on twitter
and on social networks currently
incentivizes all the wrong things
and i i believe it's possible to hate
anger adrenaline
things that cause adrenaline yeah things
that cause outrage addiction
not growth happiness
and generally just the kindness towards
each other is not encouraged
and i just have a fundamental belief
that most people want to be kind
and intelligent i agree and i feel like
that's
it's it's popular to think that they
don't
it's popular to think that most people
are stupid and most people are assholes
i just don't believe that but i also
think we we only amplify the worst i
mean i don't have to tell you this but
it's sort of
the things we see we only see that we're
only exposed to that because that's the
only thing that gets the clickbait
and the likes and drives the traffic we
now take a break from our
programming with a programmer to talk
about
my favorite cereal
i i feel weird talking about magic spoon
in an ad
because i would do it for free
i mean i believe that i am so obsessed
with magic spoon cereal and i feel like
you guys
think i'm only saying that because they
sponsor the podcast
but i truly would say it if i didn't
yeah she's not we've
there's been magic spent in this house
long before they bought an ad
and i mean there's enough magic spent
boxes we could build a fort and live in
it
we get magic spoon deliveries didn't i
tell you to stop the deliveries at some
point because i was or i had ordered so
much
yeah and then they come anyways so every
time i come home there's another magic
spoon delivery because i'm so
worried about running out honestly we
should just start delivering the ones we
have we have so many extras
we could build a house out of the magic
spoon
boxes that we have here's okay
so you know about magic spoon you've
heard about it
but i need you to understand how
important it is to your emotional
health it's got no sugar 12 grams of
protein
three net carbs in each serving here's
why that's important
we all have body stuff we do i'm not
gonna pretend like i'm just
any i can eat anything and not feel
shame or guilt
or be preoccupied what did i just eat
should i have to go for a run i have to
work out oh i just ate that now i can't
eat this
there's no rigmarole with magic spoon
there's no mental
energy that has to come in and undo
shame or guilt i just i like eat it and
i just can move on without
feeling bad about myself and it's fun
it's it looks like a kid's cereal and i
want to eat kids cereal without having
the body of a baby
we both get different emotional benefits
from this
um i just like there's no guilt there's
no shame
afterwards and it's also i l i'm
obsessed with cereal
but most cereal is just pure sugar and
to be able to
have a cereal that tastes like fruit
loops without going into diabetic shock
yeah this cereal gives you um instead of
giving you that like sugar high rush
that you crash off of
it makes you feel full throughout the
day you can go about get stuff done
but you had fun cereal i think that's
really important
it's like fun without all the shame
that's the best thing that's the worst
thing about fun is usually shame follows
this is the only fun
without shame what's your favorite
flavor of magic
uh the fruity one by far no me too my
favorite i know i'm upset look i mean
i'm not like true this is not a joke i'm
truly eating it right
yes one time i went to the beginning i'm
always eating magic sponge one time i
went in the bathroom there was a bowl
sitting in the floor that you were
eating and i was like was shooting this
in the bathroom i also eat it like
between meals it's also a snack for me i
eat it before
bed yeah i ate at night if i want
something very much just a substitute
for a man at this point
there's different flavors there's four
there's cocoa fruity frosted and
blueberry
i actually like the blueberry one too
but i just the fruity one just i think
it just i don't know it
makes me feel nice yeah it feels
nostalgic like you're eating like some
fancy like saturday morning cartoon
series that's right instead you're going
to work
keto friendly gluten free grain free
soy free low carb and gmo free
guilt free shame free the only thing in
it's magic
yeah every time i take a bite of it i'm
like
you just disappear you show up at a new
place you're like who sold me in half
it is magic spoon is magic because it
makes your shame disappear
keto friendly tada
go to magicspoon.com the real magic of
this would be if we can
actually read the copy without
stuttering grab a variety pack
try it today be sure to use our promo
code whitney at checkout to get
free shipping magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's back
with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money
no questions asked but that won't happen
unless you're a psychopath or unless
you've lost your
taste from covent that's magicspoon.com
whitney use the code whitney for free
shipping we thank magic spoon
for sponsoring this podcast even if you
don't sponsor this podcast thank you for
your product
yeah thank you for keeping whitney alive
i'm just a fan
i love talking about ritual i love
talking
about period that stands out
no i just love sharing with people the
things that made my life better
and ritual vitamins have done that for
me
and i find i guess this is why they
sponsor the podcast because i was
already using them
yeah you have been using metroid i i
don't think people know that like
i think a lot of people just get random
sponsorships from random like i don't
get i don't work with sponsors that i
the products if i didn't use the
products already yeah and we know that
i'm just saying i've been using i've
been using ritual you were using ritual
before i knew you uh i walked in it was
in your cabinet already well here's the
great thing about ritual
is that my problem with vitamins or
anything healthy is that i'll do it once
and then i'll forget because i if you
don't develop it as a habit
and they just send it to you every month
so as soon as i'm running out like i
have no excuse to not take it and i have
my brain can't
sneakily not do it
my brain wants to be unhealthy my brain
wants to just eat trash my brain wants
to deprive me of vitamins
yeah your brain wants to have fun but
but ritual like it just shows up at your
door and you're like ah i guess i'm
gonna be healthy and only that but you
know you take vitamins and you're like
well i think this vitamin is like
works you don't really know the ritual
is science-backed and they mean it well
most vitamins are sketchy
i'm telling you most vitamins a lot of
that sounds crazy
it sounds like a conspiracy theory like
q anon hot take but like
a lot of vitamins are full of chemicals
and like trash
which is why i love ritual and this
woman cat schneider
who invented ritual and her team of
scientists are making clinically tested
a new normal not only have they
obsessively researched each nutrient in
their visionary women's multivitamin
carefully choosing uh forms that are
absorbable to the body that's the other
thing half the vitamins you're taking
aren't even absorbing
i hate to break it to you i'm sorry you
have to hear this from me
but they have also tested their formula
it's science backed
that is their standard ritual has no
mystery additives no sketchy fragrances
or fillers or
chemicals or red number five or
pain or right it's just a multivitamin
that you can really use
yes really absorbs into your body and
it's it's science and you only put
science in your mouth really
and also if you're vegetarian or vegan
have dietary restrictions
your multivitamin might be undermining
that
not ritual they use vegan certified
non-gmo
gluten-free allergen free ingredients
and their
sources are out there for the whole
world to see because they have nothing
to hide like mostly sketchy
pyramid scheme multi-level marketing
scam vitamin companies you know who i'm
you know why you know you know i'm
talking to keith renair
renee ritual is designed to be gentle on
an empty stomach that is the worst
that is literally the worst nothing
makes you want to be unhealthy more than
taking something healthy and then
spending your whole life in a bathroom
like you just don't want to do it
there's nothing worse than like trying
to be healthy and then you take your
vitamin and then you're just burping up
like oyster for the rest of you yeah you
like go to a dinner party your stomach's
just growling the whole time
what's wrong with you and you're like
i'm healthy it doesn't smell like worf
oh sorry that's just my vitamins it's so
nice that they've like not
rich it doesn't that is gentle on an
empty stomach ritual
uses vegan algal oil
instead of fish oil which comes from the
fermentation of micro
algae a patented process that leaves
minimal environmental contamination
awesome they don't kill fish so that you
can think better
40 of women cannot properly utilize the
synthetic form of
folic acid which can be found in a lot
of multivitamins
wow this is why my hair was falling out
in my 20s
this is why ritual uses folate in its
absorbable form to help
cover women's needs that's awesome
you want to read the green yep daily
changes can lead to big results so start
small today rituals offering whitney's
listeners ten percent off your first
three months try it out satisfaction
guaranteed go to ritual.com
whitney to start your ritual today
that's ten percent off during your first
three months it's not
optional at ritual.com whitney you know
it's interesting like
this pandemic being alone for you know
six months or whatever i just realized i
was like i'm so much happier than i
thought i was
i'm so much um
lighter than i thought i was and what i
realized is that
humans are so triggering to me you know
anytime you're around a human
you know we have this history together
with when i had a robot for my special
sounds weird i know that sounds very
weird um
but there's something when i got this
wrong i'm in this weird situation where
i do have a robot that looks exactly
like me and she kind of talks she's not
perfect i need you to kind of give her a
tune up at some point
but i like who i am more when i'm with
her
because i'm not this is like my
relationship with animals
this is why people ask me why i love
animals so much i love being around
horses and i love being around dogs
because i don't feel like i have to
perform
i don't feel like i have to protect
myself to me humans
for the most part whether it's nature
whether it's nurture whether it's
biology whether
this is universal or super specific to
me
humans scare me i feel scared i'm afraid
they're going to reject me i'm afraid
they're
going to laugh at me i'm afraid they're
not going to like me so the amount of
energy i have to put into performing for
them and
managing them and i'm sort of fighting
this mini war with every human i meet
and when i'm around this robot
my defenses are down and i am the best
version of myself that's beautifully put
and i think everybody's like that to a
degree
i think i think i think once you have
robots that are actually intelligent no
offense to your what
uh hey
[Laughter]
and they will listen and you will feel
truly heard
when your guard is down is you learn a
lot about yourself
and you'll make you a better human
in facing other human beings i think we
are better people when we're not around
people because when i'm around people i
want to win
i want to compete i want to be right i
have all these
my ego in relationships too
no i think in relationships for me it's
i think when i was younger i wanted to
be right and all that because i
i thought i had to prove how smart i was
my relationship with my dad made me
you know he was always testing me and
pushing me uh to fight with him that was
like a big part of our relationship is
you know
defend yourself he was i now realize he
was preparing me for the world at the
time i felt like i was being abused and
attacked
but he was really just trying to make
sure that anytime i said something i
could defend my point
you know and so i'd say like i want to
stay until in the morning
why give me three reasons why i should
be able to stay out until two in the
morning and defend them you know it was
like
um but now no i i want to be in a
relationship with someone who's
let you guard down wildly smarter than
me oh wow
yeah if i can be unified i'll lose
respect for you and i can't
get that wop wait you just said wait a
minute
you just said two different things you
want somebody more intelligent than you
and in a fight
oh intellectual fight well i just mean i
want i want to be in awe of someone
i know that i need that if i lose i
think to me
i was listening to you talk about love
with michael malus i think
and to me i i it's we're all different
i need to respect the person if i lose
respect for the person
everything i can't that's interesting
what's the basis of respect like what
makes you respect
discipline and self-control if so if i
see someone if i see someone lose
control of themselves i lose respect for
them
and i can't get the wop so like angry
the word wob makes me uncomfortable i'm
sorry i feel like i've made you
uncomfortable for a while now
there should be a word for the opposite
of wob for guys or something like that
i'm like pitching on this all right
i'm gonna get cancelled
[Laughter]
no i mean at some point when am i not
gonna be able to get away with the
things that men are not able to get away
with i mean if rogan said
any of the things i just have said to
you this entire podcast people would be
like he's so sexist he's hitting on that
girl
yeah oh enjoy the freedom i know i feel
like i have like a another like year
where i'm allowed to sexually harass my
guests and not get in trouble
i'm just trying to really enjoy it yeah
what were we talking about we were
talking about um
uh respect in relationships because your
definition of love you and
listening to you and michael malus who
i'm kind of fast i'm fascinated by him
uh the legitimate troll yeah probably
he's very provocative i i appreciate
provocateurs we're at this time where
we're all begging to infantilize
ourselves we don't want anyone to
challenge us we don't want anyone to
have opinions different than ours and
i love to get in a room with someone i
disagree with and mentally spar i don't
think they have to be deleted or blocked
or removed from society if we all had
the same opinion on everything life
would be like super boring and nothing
would ever get done you don't block
people on social media i do if they
it's interesting if they insult one of
my guests
oh that's the only time i block them if
they insult me you love me but you
welcomed
you're flirting you're obsessed with me
so i i don't understand
that you welcome dick pics this part of
this this
i'm trying to understand are you just
doing like a psychology experiment in
all of society
kind of yeah yeah i don't in a hand
towel thing that doesn't
i feel like judged that was that's kind
of like
i feel like you're stuck on that you're
stuck on that yeah i think i
i think black hand towels is just you
need i just think
that you need a woman's touch that's all
it's the only color on which like if you
mur if you murder somebody
the blood you know so we call a red flag
literally copy that um exactly why i'm
saying don't date guys
i'm virtue signaling yeah dexter had
black hand towels as well no but usually
i can go into a man's bathroom
and tell you exactly what stage of
single they are
okay so what what are so if you do a
quick analysis okay
you go in your bathroom first of all
tell me what's in your bath how much
how much time do you have to make the
analysis because it'd be rude if you
just stay there for 10 minutes i would
need a gander
at most a gander so quick and uh the the
medicine cabinet too
are you gonna look at it might not even
need it but sure okay
i could look at your shower and tell you
if you're in a relationship
cheating just getting out of one bit out
of one for six months
is there a loofah is there a loofah is
it like a sliver of
of old crusty irish spring is that if
there's
shave cream in there that's pink you
have a girlfriend
what about long hair long hair yes
you're with someone
that's a good point like that your
shampoo your if it's a prell if it's
like a head and shoulders or like a
prell
two-in-one you're single yeah you're not
lying
you don't have a secret girl oh that's a
good thing yeah so you're not well yeah
i can tell you so if a guy's like i'm
single and i go into your
bathroom and you've got you know st
knives apricot face scrub you have a
girlfriend
right because guys can't see it for some
reason when girls leave their products
at a guy's house they like can't see
them it's like this amazing thing where
maybe they're trying to make you jealous
like make you work harder
like jealousy doesn't make me work
harder uh uh
you lying to me doesn't make me like you
more i'm not in my twenties lex
that is now a red flag and i take this
in your twenties and i'm out of there
thank you
see how you did that see i mean
look no one take notes kids
[Laughter]
so do you ultimately think
that we're gonna be marrying robots do
you want to be in a relationship with a
robot in your lifetime
romantically i want to be careful saying
this because you know people would be
like of course he's single
the guy looks like you know of course he
wants to marry a robot
i do think we're going to have deep
relationships with robots
that but i don't think i think it'll be
a very very long time
before like where a human will be worse
than a robot
in the full fulfilling nature of what a
relationship is
but i have a very 20th century
conception of a monogamous relationship
it's also possible what does that mean
i'm sorry meaning like monogamy
you'd believe in it yeah so why is that
why is that 20th century sorry can you
say
okay i wanted to say it in in the
following way that it's
possible that in like 20 30 50 years
the way the relationships will change
maybe there's something about
the digital world that will change our
willingness to be in a monogamous
relationship
and will like vr sex count as cheating
does it
would you if you were in a relationship
with someone would you let them have vr
sex with another man
oh with a real human yeah well a vr
no i know but i thought maybe like a
video game because that's also a thing
you tell me i'm outclassed right now
i'm in over my head i'm pretty vanilla
i'm pretty vanilla but you know more
about this than i do
why so you think just because i like in
build robots you think just because i
build robots i'm smart
into like the latest porn technology no
i just i just
mean like is having vr sex
cheating
that means yes yeah yeah probably
yeah probably but then like is porn
cheating
that's a tricky one you strike me as
someone that doesn't watch porn
so you can deprive yourself yeah uh
no i i watch porn the anime kind yeah
like with snakes and dragons and
whatever
no a pretty vanilla porn i am scared of
porn like what it does to
kids like young kids to desensitize yeah
like if i had porn when i was
10 or 11 or 12. like like online porn
yeah that'd be scary yeah terrifying
like
i think the biggest this to dating apps
the biggest problem with porn
i think is the switching it's like
the choice like the guys i've talked to
about porn
it's they don't like they commit to the
one
point they keep like they keep like next
next next i don't think i if i'm with
someone i don't think i want them
watching the same porn star every time
they're not that now they're in a
relationship that's kind of weird
you follow him on twitter yeah like
you're with a porn star
like that's i can only like i don't want
to cheat on my porn star with another
porn star like that now you're in a
relationship you're probably thinking
about that porn star when they're with
you
yeah what if i just started crying you
just broke my heart you just broke my
heart
i i have such a conflicted relationship
with porn because
as someone i can watch porn and it
doesn't but i don't
i watch it so infrequently that i i
think from what i understand with guys
that watch it it's like a daily thing
and i can see how that desensitizes
them and i've also in
dating again this last year um
and before i was engaged i definitely
saw the impact of porn and guys sexually
where they just come out swinging and
they think they need to choke you
and and fish hook you up they literally
are like
like digging your eye sockets out you're
just like okay hold on to time like
timeout
i feel like so i don't know what you're
talking about with the fish hooking but
i feel like i feel like fishing they're
pulling your nostrils
i mean it's really i'm like wait are you
watching mma or porn i'm not sure what
exactly
where this is all coming from but i feel
like people only talk about the effects
of porn on women
and i was talking about this the other
day with romantic comedies people only
talk about the effect of romantic
comedies
on men women saw them on women men saw
them too
men learned you have to make grandiose
gestures you show up at a woman's house
with a stereo like john cusack you hold
it up
you show up at women's work without
asking you ambush women you know like
romantic comedies taught men to stalk
women right and
porn is also i feel like has negative
effects on men and that when they
come into the bedroom they think they
need to just like
be like cirque du soleil performers that
just like beat the shit out of us now
uh yeah i don't know what to i don't
know where to go with that
[Laughter]
but you're right i'm pretty vanilla
though so
yeah i but because we were talking about
vr and the future of that talking about
love i think yeah
because i want to ask your definition of
it because i want to fight with you
about it
okay well i i think that
robots will for a long time serve the
role
of just being friends
which our phone already kind of is right
we already
but your phone exactly beautifully put
but the phone doesn't know much about
you
and it'd be nice if the phone listened
like literally listen to who you are
privately like there's a bunch of stuff
that is broken about the way
current social networks work one is they
totally disrespect your
right to privacy they don't give you
control over your data they assume
people aren't intelligent
they're not transparent with the
decisions they make and if all of that
is there
i feel like you would be willing to give
like to teach another ai system
another digital being about yourself
that so it can make you feel so you can
be heard and through that process learn
about yourself
like i truly believe there is like you
you think about like a therapist
uh in his best form which is what
friendship is which is what
relationships are
as you you you're heard you're
understood
somebody takes the time to really listen
well how about this
for the first eight years or whatever i
was going to a therapist i lied to her
in terms of lying to the therapist i
believe most people are lying to
themselves
including the two of us to some degree
to each ot to ourselves
that i like we don't that's one of the
things i learned with a podcast is like
we don't prod our psyche enough
like basically to put another way the
therapist that we pay for
i've never been to a therapist but if
you go to a therapist
is they're just not very good they're
not good at
truly prodding into the depths of our
psyche well they want to just keep you
coming they just want to make you feel
good so you'll keep coming back
yeah that's a whole other thing but you
know
it's interesting you say that like
because i think
just the same way you would update
software update your computer update
your phone whatever you have to update
your own mental software of like
is this still true about me like is this
just a story that i have about myself
like you know i'm insecure i'm single
right like
i think we become robots frankly
sometimes
um and we sort of um
constantly have to update our software
in terms of our perceptions of ourselves
and our psyche well
one of the problems with social media i
try to make sure there's zero gap
between who i truly am and who i present
myself
online interesting i mean that's i feel
like you've succeeded with that
yeah but it's easier it's actually
easier for uh when it's not my career
like i worry about looking at your
internet presence
because you're always like super excited
super having all this kinds of fun
it's difficult because i feel like
there's a pressure to perform
as opposed to but that's not what you do
that's not what you're selling right
that's not your product
well see for me it's it's pretty like
because when you come out with your home
robot
i'm not i'm not gonna buy it because you
were running around with
girls in bikinis at the pool like i do
it on mine i do it because i'm like
he's a serious person that i respect
well actually so the interesting thing
is
i'd like to be different than a
zuckerberg or even a jack dorsey
because one of the biggest things i hate
is marketing teams
at some of these uh some of these places
so like
they they hide away the depth of the who
the person really is
like i don't think mark zuckerberg knows
how to show
his real self to the world and it's a
huge problem your eyes are so blue today
thanks i've been crying
[Laughter]
best fiends
best fiends you know what's the worst
being alone with your thoughts
there's just nothing worse than socrates
than having to sit there and think about
your past and
maul in your own nasty emotions and your
anxiety
when you could be exercising your brain
with this fun
puzzle game best fiend the only thing
better than a best friend
is the best fiend is the best fiend best
fiends
has helped me avoid my inner monologue
for months now
i love it i'm playing with friends in
nashville you are we're competing how
come we're not friends
i don't know why we're not friends
that's a great question we're not
we're gonna tell them we're best friends
we're not best beings i literally
love i love talking trash as a bug
you know how exciting that's a little
video game let's explain what yeah it's
a video game it's a puzzle game where
you solve every level has like a
different challenge of colors
or tasks you have to do you have to blow
this many things up or use it it's like
a puzzle game that doesn't make you
stupider yeah it's like it's
kind of difficult sometimes yeah you
have only have so many moves but you
have little characters that are bugs and
they find slugs which is
so cute i love that they're just like
chubby little like cute like sluggy
buggy
bubbies and it's like a reward i love
reward based things and like you can
then why do you hang out with me
well we know we're working on it um and
like you can level the characters up and
they look different they change
it's oh yeah yeah yeah and they're gonna
change for halloween hot hot tip
but i guess i just like i don't know i
just feel like
you know this is such a great way to
train your brain
to do something fun and healthy instead
of something toxic and unhealthy like
instead of texting your ex
go play best fiends like when you feel
level up a spider
yeah when you like feel compelled to
like call your mom who's just gonna make
you feel bad about yourself
play best fiends like i'm trying to
retrain my brain to instead of doing
self to something self-destructive on my
phone to go do something like playful
and fun
and um everybody needs more fun you have
there's over 100 million downloads on
this game so
we're not alone it's not just us it's
not a hot take that this is a fun game
it's fun we're super unoriginal and if
you're bored instead of scrolling
mindlessly
right now you can pull this up no wi-fi
needed i also get so anxious on planes
my new thing is that when i'm waiting
for the plane to take off i'll just play
it there's that like 20 minutes where
you're like can't really get work done
you can't really focus and you don't
want to just like sit there and like
be anxious i just played this game and
then i'm like huh just like passes the
time in a way that doesn't make me feel
like ugh i just wasted the whole time
they're telling me how to survive a
crash playing this game
i have no idea how to survive that but i
know that i will level up that ladybug
best fiends engage your brain with the
fun
puzzles and collect tons of cute
characters trust me with over a hundred
million downloads this five star rated
mobile puzzle game is a must play
download best fiends free on the apple
app store or google play
that's friends without the r best fiend
yeah that's not just our stutters
best fiends that's not just benton being
southern word of the day
fiend you know what
i think what the only way i could love
doordash more
is if they delivered friends to my house
back up back up are you trying to tell
me
that baked beans is not a friend
best friend i've ever had listen
doordash is
i couldn't survive without okay let's
you guys know what doordash is
you already know what it is if you've
downloaded it congratulations if you use
it congratulations you have high
self-esteem and you know how to live a
quality life
if you have it let me just let me just
tell you something mister i just spit
all over myself
life is a nightmare life is a series
of nightmares and the goal is to just
navigate each nightmare with a modicum
of grace this is uplifting i'm just
saying
there's so much hard stuff going on
right now
there's so much we can't control if
there's one thing you can control one
thing you can make it easier in your
life
freaking do it eat your feelings
i'm seeing the rigmarole of like making
food like going to the grocery store
just like
treat yourself the last thing you need
is to like
cut yourself freaking trying to make
dinner or like
doing that extra i just find that like
ordering food
from doordash and just like how it's
just like it makes the
easy thing easy easy things should be
easy and hard things should be hard
i don't think easy things should be hard
does that make sense
it does i'm just saying anything you
deserve to make your life a little bit
easier
that's what i'm finding with just food
delivery and having like door dash just
like
it just makes life like 10 percent
easier yeah and it's
you can also you know i love to make
things fun sometimes i'll order doordash
and then i'll i'll get really busy doing
something i'll forget and then i have
like a surprise delivery
i ordered three pies yesterday i brought
a pie here today you did
from house of pies benton ordered pies
off
of doordash i was ordering one slice of
pie ordered three
full pies i said well
that's not helping me out in any there's
nothing but honestly there's just
nothing that feels better than like
summoning
a man to bring you food even though it's
doordash
i'm saying it's it lately has been
mostly male drivers and i like to
pretend that my doordash
driver is like uh ex-boyfriend who's
just like i'm sorry
here's your chicken sandwich you like to
think they're repenting for the
patriarchy
yes there's something that makes me feel
very powerful to be like yes give me my
creamed corn now through the fence
jordan cream corn yes i love i i order
i've been eating a lot of corn i know
other day order would you order fried
pickles and jalapeno pops oh
my god i am so obsessed the this one
place that i ordered from outdoor dash
they have
fried zucchini chips fried pickles fried
jalapeno poppers and buffalo
cauliflower and i ordered like three
days a week you looked at me with a
mouthful of food and said want a
jalapeno popper
the door dodge drivers are starting to
be like ah here's your poppers again
carnival
ma'am
i know i eat like um someone at the
roman
coliseum watching a gladiator eating
fried pickles in the gym
you're like okay uh can you read the
official doordash copy
right now our listeners can get five
dollars off their first order of 15.
that's like one
serving of fried pickles just saying and
zero delivery fees for their first month
when you download the doordash app and
enter code whitney that's five dollars
off your first order and zero delivery
fees for a month
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter code whitney
don't forget that's code whitney for
five dollars off your first order with
doordash
yes one of the things that internet
encouraged
of me is to be real is to be flawed
well elon's probably the best example of
someone who's shown his personality and
it
works even though it's yeah mercurial
and
exactly he's one of the people that
inspires me to like you can just be
yourself
if it's weird just be yourself yeah but
you don't have to be the product you're
making a product as well you don't
you know but i believe you do have to be
the product interesting
it's like if people are going to trust
the things you create yeah you have to
be real
that's part of that's the elon musk
thing too like
they're not going to if you're going to
be a mark zuckerberg who never shows up
on camera except he's when he's making
some meats on a barbecue
i don't know if you've seen that he
talks about i love meat
he talks about all these kinds of
different meats and it's the creepiest
thing
well no i know i heard something about
the how he like
kills his own goats or something wasn't
jack dorsey telling a story about how
he went to mark zuckerberg's house to
have dinner and they're like you want to
kill your goat for
with a laser beam or something yeah the
whole thing just felt like a cartoon
villain
that's where money gets in the way money
can detach you from society that's why i
hate money
i'll always give away money it's
interesting that you were saying that
like twitter's negative and it made me
think or just like what we see online is
negative i do also think that
we're in this moment where men are
having to have this like rude awakening
as well because i'm not surprised by
negativity online like women are not as
thrown by it i think because we're used
to catcalling we're used to
we're used to trolls where you you know
like there's i just i get excited
talking to you about stuff like this
sorry i just flipped my computer over
guys i got excited
about this point i'm making um like
the fear of robots and the
surprise at how negative
the internet can be to me is a little
bit exclusive
to men if i may generalize for a second
because
you know it's so funny to me when
rogan's afraid of robots
it's like robots are going to kill us
it's like oh my god this is the first
time
experience you've been scared of
something because you've you've always
been the most powerful
scary dangerous thing whereas women are
always used to something that might
eventually
overpower us and kill us yeah but it
doesn't make it okay like i'm
one of the things that disagree with
rogan on is he always says don't read
the comments
i mean the another version of that is
you saying don't pay attention to the
comments like
the negativity in the comments uh to me
yes that's good advice personally but
like i actually have the ability to
change that
like like i said i either i want to
build it
or i want to encourage other people like
collaborate with people that want to
build a competitor
and create communities that are actually
positive
like it's not okay the toxicity that we
see in comments
i do but i also think that for me i
believe that any kind of anger and
negativity is all coming from pain
so when i see negative comments i don't
go look at all this fucking toxic
negativity i'm like oh my god there's so
many people that are in pain
i need to work even harder and be even
funnier and try to help
heal these people these people are in
pain you don't write a negative comment
to somebody
because your life is going great and you
feel great it's like a drug
well that's great i mean that that's the
way you should probably see it but for
them individually
they might not even understand that
they're being assholes
and you that's a responsibility on the
platform
to make them realize that like help help
them understand like put a mirror to
them
and help them understand that they are
when they are being toxic that they're
being
toxic and how to be kinder and that it's
ultimately rewarding to be kind
like that that that's at the individual
level the same way that
when we're two humans sitting together
and we can see the pain that we cause to
each other for
being like assholes to each other like
mean to each other
the same thing should be possible on the
internet
but i think it's also important to look
at that and maybe this is just me and my
sort of maternal comedian
uh you know take but like you know i do
believe her people hurt people
as cliche as that platitude is you know
anyone
who is being negative to us was injured
in some way psychology something
happened to them
right like i get very
thrown when i think about how you know
most pedophiles were molested
as kids and it's like you know that's
like a hard one to process so it's like
when you see people that are in this
kind of pain i go okay how can we break
the cycle
and maybe we break the cycle because lex
is going to make these robots that
kids are going to be able to have that
are going to help them learn to
self-soothe and manage their anger and
manage their pain or
give them the love that the their dad or
mom can't you know fill in
the blind spots or fill in the you know
um give them the attention they never
got of the eye contact they never got or
something so that we can
stop the invisible wounds from being
created so then we can stop
the pain and hence what turns into anger
yeah but because you can't just tell
someone who's 35 years old stop being
negative it's like well i've
got i've got what's up invisible wounds
for my childhood that's not how it works
yeah but you have to help them realize
when they are being that and then just
one step at a time and you you help them
improve
like the the system that incentivizes
behavior
on social networks with the likes and
all that needs to encourage you to be
a better version of yourself get
rewarded for kindness instead of
negativity
it's not as simple like the words are
not exactly right here because it's not
always kindness but to be a better
version of yourself
every time so like the same kind of
thing when i do difficult
when i do difficult things like jiu
jitsu and all that kind of stuff
it's that that humbling process
is really effective at like looking
within yourself
to try to improve and i think
everybody's capable of that
even people who've been through trauma
to like
face their demons to face the dark like
it doesn't have to be
like extreme it can be just like
i think more what's more common is just
basic jealousy like
you you have a dream you wanted to be a
musician
it's not working out and so you go on
all these musicians pages and you shit
on their
content like you say negative stuff to
them because really you wanted to be a
great musician
and instead you're experiencing all
kinds of jealousy but
i think what you have like and so the
for that kind of person what you have to
realize is it feels really good and
in fact is inspiring if you are instead
encouraging of those musicians
or just say kind things and that allows
you to
that like mental positivity opens up
the world of possibilities for you like
you can actually
you know like achieve your dreams or
change your dreams like pivot to what
you can't actually
achieve then you feel better like when i
leave if i could never leave when i see
people leaving negative comments i'm
like
i would feel like shit if i did that
like i would
you know feel dirty i'd feel shame but
we're leaving out that a lot of people
are addicted to shame a lot of people
are addicted to feeling like shit a lot
of people that's the
you know and i think that and we'll talk
about neurolink in a second like
like that to me is the biggest potential
for that is to
is we have to address addictive behavior
in the way addicts think
and shame addiction we don't understand
shame addiction
because we don't have it necessarily but
i
i have experienced it a little bit not
at this juncture in my life but a lot of
people are addicted to feeling like shit
and making their outsides match their
insides because they have toxicity
inside they're self-loathing
you know i saw it with roseanne i'm just
gonna say it this will probably get me
in trouble but i watched somebody that
like everyone loved her and she just had
to make them all hate her so she had
some kind of homeostasis or equilibrium
or whatever it is
that huberman i think talks about this a
little bit too where your outsides need
to match your inside there's some people
that go to new york
in their internal chaos they feel calm
in new york because outside is chaos and
inside is chaos we're matched now right
so it's like the same with if you hate
yourself
making other people hate you or creating
toxicity makes you feel calm
and that has a basis in dopamine
receptors and addictive behavior and
nature and nurture and all of it but
i just feel like we're not talking
having a big conversation
about addiction and mental illness the
way we should we're acting like
everybody has the same tools in their
toolbox
in terms of rewarding kindness it's like
okay but some people
get off on their sadistic some people
get off on shame some people get off on
humiliating themselves you know so it's
like but yeah
the the whether i'm wrong or not i don't
know but my basic assumption is
once they once most people try being
kind
try get addicted to that feeling yeah
they
they get addicted to the results it
creates so like you just need to give it
a chance
like but if there's a algorithm or
whatever look at me trying to use
science words
um if there's a
algorithm spider program in place
well that's my biggest fear so because
we're all in an algorithm is that safe
to say
yeah are you mad at me uh
what are you thinking are we in a fight
are we in a fight
uh it's not your fault what do you mean
it's not your fault because i feel like
you i got you full
i conflate with you you're sometimes
reticent but sometimes i think you're
sad but i can't tell if i'm projecting
no i feel like i've dropped from a four
out of ten to three out of ten
why no i just i feel like this is going
great
well are you not having fun i'm having a
lot of fun are you miserable
are you mad at me the worse you think
you're doing the better this is going so
i'm fine with you
grading yourself harshly the question is
this
because if we're all in these algorithms
now and we're all only getting news
that is being catered to us are we all
just going to get
stupider do you need more coffee i just
saw you take a sip of an empty cup
no there's there's stuff in there but i
thought i'm gonna have to answer
something in a second so i was like
no don't worry my question it won't be
it takes me about 45 seconds to answer
very s
to phrase this simple question i'll wait
so you have plenty of time to take a
drink
this should be four words and i'm going
to find a way to make it 50 words i
think you already forgot the question
100 i'm just sort of treading water over
here algorithms
like i was with who was i with uh taylor
tomlin this weekend we were touring and
we were both in denver and like we both
go to the same news site and she has
like different news than i do
like mine's all like dog rescue videos
and shit right
and like i'm like wait we're getting
different news
based on i shouldn't only get the news
that i'm interested in i need to
this is my concern with our lives being
so
um organized by what we want
i remember walking around new york and i
suck at new york
the more i go there the less i know how
to navigate it
and i was using waze last time i was
there and i got to the hotel and didn't
get lost and i was like
i kind of wish i had gotten lost like
some of the most magical moments and
some of the most interesting things
i've done or like i took a wrong turn
and i stumbled into this
store that i never would have seen
otherwise and i've seen new york
i met this person that i never would
have met and like then we dated for
10 years and then we dated for 10 years
yeah
and then he murdered me yeah um so
what what do we do about that about like
how our program gonna have our lives
down to a t
and smart for lack of a better word but
is there we're gonna have smart homes
we're gonna have smart cars is there any
argument to stay stupid yeah 100 so
first of all let's say let's not take
for granted how amazing it
is that if you enjoy watching videos of
dogs
that these algorithms bring more videos
of dogs to you like we take for granted
how magical that is
but is there anything to be said for
diminishing marginal returns which is
like the reason i like them so much is
because i only see one a day not 50 a
day there's a balance of stress now i'm
sick of dogs how did that happen it's
like your point of scarcity
yeah right but so there's a balance of
strike but it's pretty cool that we're
able to do that
you know that that we can bring our
interest to us so
it's just that the algorithms currently
are are quite
dumb and not optimized for the right
kind of thing i think it's great to see
videos of dogs
if you're interested in dogs but also
mix stuff up
like you don't want most of your life to
be complete chaos as generic you want
you do want to cultivate your interest
and like go down rabbit holes and you're
just like i'm sure rogan who's
into alien the text 99 of text i've been
getting from joe rogan the past month
have been about aliens well because he's
texting you about aliens so he's
probably getting more articles about
aliens and it becomes like a
so he also he wants like approval from
somebody who is
a quote-unquote scientist the aliens are
real so you're not a quote-unquote
scientist well i'm not i believe that's
a good that's a good
um dating app bio though quote-unquote
scientists i just
yeah i'm very good with the bios if you
need help
uh what what what makes a goodbye what
let's go look what makes it what makes a
good bio what are the pictures in your
bio
uh actually you would love my dating app
okay so this is my this is my raya my
dating app main photo
it's me as half a robot that's really
good
and kind of disturbingly hot would you
swipe right on that
benton did my makeup for halloween uh
last year
as a half robot that's weirdly
attractive zombie
well i mean i feel like quote-unquote
scientist would definitely be into this
i mean that's amazing that's an amazing
picture because it's like this person
has a sense of humor
yeah they're obviously gorgeous and like
i don't know and then my second photo is
hold on i forgot you have to like play a
song hold on this is the whole thing oh
i have to start it okay then my robot is
my second picture
very close my second picture then me and
an ape
subliminal messaging then i don't know
what that is
i yeah these are all really weird me in
vietnam while you have something i
travel
i'm selfie like really then me and my
dog
wow that's going you gotta have the dog
yeah all my photos are
given yeah what's your bio say uh
comedian comedian
i don't like joke jobs i don't like joke
jobs i don't like it when
someone under work writes like sometimes
or a lot or
or the most annoying thing is when a
when a
um a guy does a fake like joke job
that's better that ends up being better
than their real job like they'll be like
hand model
and you're like oh ha ha he must be like
a ceo or you must have and then you're
like what are you doing he's like i'm
self-employed you're like i'd rather you
be a hand model
yeah your joke was better yeah than your
real job you fucking tool
what's uh so these one of my problems
actually with the reason i don't use
apps
is they don't have a way to like really
specify
who you are i feel like well no i mean
i feel like it's all about pictures and
like
what kind of music you like and like a
possibility to say some clever shit
and like yeah but that's just an opening
jumping off point yeah but that's
very inefficient there needs to be some
kind of intrigue though this is my
concern
and i text you last night um about super
sad true love story
the book that i'm adapting for hbo you
guys i don't think i've talked about on
this podcast but
it's about it's a dystopian satire about
dating in the future
and how hard it's going to be to fall in
love with
a lack of privacy like if i know
everything about you right away there's
no mystery there's no
ability to sort of uh project on to you
like i think there needs to be a certain
amount of omissions in order to fall in
love with somebody if you know two
the key to falling in love i think is
you meet someone
they hide their flaws and mistakes for
the most part you get chemically
addicted to them and bonded with them
four months in they're like and by the
way i have three duis and it's like well
fuck i'm already in love with you
and i'm gonna just go like oh well it
was part of your journey and you are who
you are because of that and i forgive it
and
like if i knew on day one you had two
duis i would never see you again
yeah yeah we rely on an absence of
information in order to fall in love
but the kind of mystery that dating apps
have is
kind of mystery i guess i don't like i
like the mystery of a stranger in a
at a bar late at night kind of thing
because there's still
there's so much more information that's
interesting about chemistry about
like your interests yeah the kind of
joke you make i don't know
i mean i guess okay so your profile is
pretty good like that
would you swipe right on that i don't i
don't i don't want to admit to swiping
on anything
i feel like i'm really stressing you out
yeah this is
is it stressing you out no well you know
i'm nervous why
i don't know this is i don't it's i'm
not you know
conversations are stressful really you
have podcasts
well no like okay so there's some
conversations you have
that you feel like if you screw up
you'll be i don't know you you feel like
you can screw up
and so like i'm nervous to screw it up i
don't where what
like when was the last time
i have very few of those now maybe the
first time i was on rogan
and with you i feel like i don't know
why it's just nervousness
for what's well you're okay i mean
i forget this is being recorded
we can always cut stuff out okay i okay
you're so you're
a beautiful woman and it's difficult for
me to
you know it makes me naturally nervous
i'm not
i've been staring at a computer screen
for a long time
with some porn on it yeah and sometimes
you want it right
sorry sorry
when i watched a podcast copy and pasted
onto a porn star's body
so when i photoshopped your head on to
these porn stars
when i watch your podcast and with
a few animated porns of me yes or no
it wouldn't be funny if my whole
apartment's just big
[Laughter]
i'm not saying that's healthy so there's
a part of the stalking thing
that i appreciate dude trust me it's
very flatter it's very
it's but i had a stalker that showed up
my house and he also
happened to have been handsome it was it
was very confusing so what do you do
with that
what do i do with that um it was really
fascinating because
he clearly was schizophrenic or has some
you know and uh that's my demo
um and he you know
went back and it was you can tell right
away if someone's
gonna be physically dangerous to you or
not i don't know if that's just a girl
thing um i talk a lot about the book the
gift of fear by gavin to becker on this
podcast about how our gut just knows if
someone's dangerous or not
all the all women that he interviewed
for this book after they were assaulted
by someone that walked them to their car
helped them with their groceries or
opened the door for them or whatever
they all were like i knew something was
off about that guy which is why you were
scared shitless when i showed up
i did jump when i saw you earlier to
trust
you insurance thanks i did open the door
looking for likes and i saw him and i
like screamed it was weird
i mean the thing a guy does like when i
enter the room is like
can i kill everybody on my way out
that's what you think when you walk into
a room
i naturally like i don't literally think
that but like
it's a kind of um it's a feeling
if you had to kill someone yeah how
would you do it
in which situation like this like yes
like if someone came in here right now
and tried to kill me and you had to kill
them how would you do it
if weapons are involved like you have to
de-escal you have to try to de-escalate
the situation
probably so like it's different but what
if you just your only option was killing
them just thought exercise
the aggression just move you have to
move really fast you have to move and
you choke them
or you just put their oh like that you
put their nose up into their brain
no jiu-jitsu is control control first
then then then kill so
take down so like it's it's like
everything tight
control probably take the back and
probably choke choke them from the back
yeah because then they can do the least
amount of damage to me
interesting yeah interesting so bring
them to the ground
like with a big takedown probably hurt
them a little bit on the on the way down
like if especially if it's hard ground
and then control
and choke but i prefer i would i think
if i wasn't
i prefer i was a hit man i would
probably
like distance so guns guns yeah
sniper and then where do you want to
shoot someone if you shoot him with a
gun the easiest way to kill him
neck heart i don't know yes you do no
yes you do i'm not i've i'm trying to
get you a girlfriend
keep talking about killing people you're
gonna have so many stalkers after this
uh yeah not probably in the head i don't
know there's a there's a movie called
leon the professional
super with natalie portman oh is she
like i feel like she's like your dream
girl
why i don't know that that to me i feel
like
i don't know maybe i'm i'm um profiling
you because i'm like star wars now
i feel like smart guys like poor
ministers
star wars shoes and star wars right swan
okay
i was like the dark natalie yeah yeah
yeah no not star wars i don't like star
wars
okay like pew pew ships pew pew yeah is
that how a scientist describes
is that what you do in your coding
pop-pop it with my shrine to whitney
cummings
i just have my ringtone pop pop can you
please get your keyboard to just go bop
bop bop every time you press
like all dolls like with your hat
just choking them from the back and now
you gave me some merch
which is great by the way so now i get
to dress up i did give lex some merch
some
merch that sold out no longer available
you got it you're never gonna wear it
i'll wear it really yeah i feel like you
only wear black and white
yeah like yeah do you ever wear colors
ironically
so the thing is with stalkers because i
think it's important because right now
you're getting a lot of
attention coming at you certainly from
women
it's interesting how when somebody
like the when i had someone whatever
stalking whatever that even means
um came at me i think i became so much
more obsessed with him
than he was with me all i did was wonder
where he was and if he was following me
on instagram and i never knew what
captioned and i shouldn't post this
donation
and then i'm every time i go outside
like i when someone gets obsessed with
you
it's amazing how you start stalking your
stalker
yeah i mean well you're like
you love neurology psychology so
i don't know if you're like me but to me
it's fascinating how their mind works
too
like what like i get that i i get the
because as someone that chased the
approval of my dad for so long i get the
i know what it's like to fixate on
something to manage
your terror and distract yourself you
were talking about the worm at the core
on
uh was it rogan i tried to talk to him
about that once
uh she definitely i mean this sheldon
solomon who wrote
warm at the core i've interviewed him
right he
because it was unclear if he's a good
interview or not and he's incredible
it's about terror management right which
but that was first
um he's the one that came up with the
one with the cause ernest becker
oh yeah ernest becker was the one that
inspired all that stuff right the terror
management
theory and essentially that because
we're the
only species that knows we're gonna die
we just have to distract ourselves
constantly am i
is describing this right to manage our
terror of death sort of what's going on
in politics this team mentality a lot of
what terror management
says is in order to manage our fear of
death
we have to have prizes and teams and
alliances
and awards and stuff so that we have
a sense of longevity and posterity right
yeah yeah he basically says that most of
human creation is
is the warm with the core at the base of
it as
has to do with our fear of mortality
which i find because i bring that up
often with people
most people don't agree with oh i 100
agree with that but it also justifies a
lot of really
you know untoward behavior like racism
and stuff you know like there's
it's it's you know which
it is what it is but i agree you're
against racism
i think it's hot take we have a lot of
hot
tastes stand to taste hot dates i mean
do you really find
that you know
do you really think that cancel cultural
is
problematic because i find that that as
i'm listening to
i was listening to your conversation
with michael malus and i hear
people talk about a lot it seems so much
bigger
to you guys than it does to me what do
you mean
i just don't good question guys in
general i feel like men it's the it's
men don't like
to be controlled they don't like when
power gets redistributed they don't
technically the the the people in power
don't like it when their power is
challenged
as someone who is not a fan of cancel
culture or
you know um virtue signaling or justice
warrior shit someone who's
strongly against it but i know why it
exists
and i can see it for what it is which is
just people throwing rocks at the
limousine as it drives by
like it's everyone inside the limo is
fine
you know that's that's a very legitimate
criticism is like
yeah the people in the limo are upset
that some rocks are being thrown
it it's very true that uh in this
process when the power structures the
institutions are being questioned
that the the powerful are getting are
being uncomfortable
but at the same time i mean it's
it's a balance that we need to strike
there's a lot of difficult
questions you have to be able to
to say and you have to be able to say
multiple sentences
and then you have to be able to change
your mind and you can't
the idea that somebody would clip out
half a half a sentence
and then make it an entire big article
that's to cancel culture that's
really important that's bad journalism
well yes and journalism is broken today
that's right clickbait
that's right that's on people's fault
that's what they saw that's the only
they didn't know it was cut out of
context
right so there's a balance to be struck
i think
but well you you have to
me as a white guy who is somewhat enjoys
intellectual conversations
and nuanced conversations you know you
have to
you have to be sensitive to the cancer
culture like i feel this at mit
there's um there was a situation that
happened with a guy named famous
computer scientist made
named richard stallman who on a thread
within mit
was talking about jeffrey epstein and
marvin minsky who's another seminal ai
figure
and some a few uh
you know like undergrads like 20 year
olds said that marvin minsky is a rapist
because jeff he's met with jeffrey
epstein and jeffrey epstein
told another a woman to walk up to
marvin minsky who was 70 years old at
the time
17 70 70. oh
oh but how was old was the girl that
walked up she was 17 yeah oh got it
but like seven year old man okay uh and
she came up to him and
you know propositioned her like he
didn't know
that it was forced or not that's first
of all and second of all
he said no okay no thank you
like politely you know and that was
that was construed as rape on this
thread within mit
and richard stallman so it was a rumor
it was hearsay
yeah but richard stallman on this thread
said
well we should be careful about how we
define rape that
that's not you know that's not the 70
year old man
wrote that on the thread yeah another
he's not 70 he's like 50. that's a
different guy okay
different guy doesn't matter but he got
fired or pushed out of
mit for saying that because the those
undergrads said that you know rape is
rape there's no
discussion of definitions or whatever
rape rape is rape and
like that's cancel culture because
here's a person who's trying to draw
that's not even nuanced that's just like
like let's try to talk about a little
bit of facts
and he gets pushed out completely did he
have to respond to that
if i may he he didn't he didn't and
that's where things get weird if there's
a situation that had nothing to do with
you
and you have to go let's just fucking
agree on what rape means it's like you
did you've done something shady
that you what do you stand to gain in
jumping into this fight that has nothing
to do with you like
you're when i see men that react to if
one man is accused of something
some men are like oh that's that sucks i
don't know if it's true or not but if
the guys go
that's fucking crazy i'm like you've
done something shady you have guilt
you have a secret and you're scared but
if you
if you do want to say something which i
think
i think the right thing to do is what
for example uh barack obama did is
be eloquent about it be be fucking good
if you're going into this war zone of
cancer culture and you want to make a
point
to this 20 year old to saying like
to say that some nuanced point
about the dangers of overusing the word
rape
you better be good at so you also i it
harms actual rape victims right
so like if you want to make that point
you better be good at it i don't know if
you heard obama talk about cancer
culture i don't think so
he's he's smooth with everything but
yeah so he
he was pretty smooth about it and so you
have to practice you have to think about
you can't just speak from emotion
and if we can learn anything that nobody
should speak from
just like from that weird dark energy
that you get like when you just want to
which robots can help solve i mean it's
sort of like feelings aren't facts but
sometimes when you
have feelings and you want to take an
action yeah so it's like i would
love to have a robot that i can like
bounce off my
like feelings aren't facts i really want
to tweet this thing is this a good idea
you know i always try to if i have a
feeling or
um come up around something my rule is
always like wait three days if you still
want to send that email if you still
want to send that tweet or that text
three days later you can do it but a lot
of us it's taken me 15 years of
like like 12-step programs and
meditation and stuff to be able to have
that pause most people don't have it
they just send it without thinking
yeah i actually know that you seem to be
the person that a lot of people run
their ideas by like comedians like
just a nightmare it's a nightmare
well joe i mean joe and i he he doesn't
like call me
this is i joke about this is why i dyed
my hair pink because so many people were
asking me for advice like i had to give
off some vibe
that i'm not together because it was
like all day every day i was
you know getting these calls should i
tweet this should i say that should i
bring this up on the podcast you know
we've had a big
reorganization and comedy not only
because of the pandemic and people
moving but also with people getting
cancelled and
yeah half the comedians got cancelled
yeah half the feet the comedians got
canceled and i'm the i'm for some reason
the metoo police
i didn't sign up for this but people
call me to be like should i say this am
i allowed to say this
and i'm like look you can say it you can
do that
but these are going to be the
consequences you can't you know it's
it's amazing sometimes to me that
comedians like we're like the
you know like warriors of free speech
and we want to be able to say whatever
the fuck we want but we don't want
anyone else to have free speech
we don't want other people to be able to
criticize us or have their feelings or
thoughts around what we say so if if
you know when comedians are like how
come i can't say tranny i'm like you can
but the people that are offended by it
they have free speech too
and they get to say that's offensive you
can't free speech isn't
only for you you can't be selectively
free speech
yeah but there's i mean it's it's a
giant mess
with with spotify so i know a lot of
folks at spotify for example
i know what's going on there with with
the rogan thing i don't think i do
you know alex jones or something was
censored uh yes
so a bunch of episodes me bringing
ketamine on the show was that censored
yeah you were sensitive
i literally brought ketamine nasal spray
i was like should we do this
they left that in yeah so they they
still haven't published a bunch of the
episodes including alex jones but also
a new one because i thought they took
down the old one no they
so first of all be you know a few months
ago there was no episodes
so they just uploaded all the episodes
of rogan on spotify
and like they didn't take anything down
they just didn't upload a bunch of the
episodes well my theory was that they
just wanted to be able to monetize it
no there's no it's it's pretty simple i
mean
they they have meetings and stuff it's
like any okay
spotify is a total noob in terms of like
getting into
they used to just publish songs and
music and
just enjoy the kind of
the non-canceled culture world of music
where you can basically say anything in
a rap song and
i was going to say yeah it doesn't get
canceled throw some d's on her
that's okay wop
what else pussy's not gross that's not
that's
that's that whole good thing i
that's awesome that's girls getting paid
i'd rather
i'd rather somebody write a song about
like a woman winning a nobel prize
what is i i don't understand why men are
allowed to sexualize us
and get paid and when we sexualize
ourselves it's like gross
it's not gross she's a stripper good for
her i'm so
pro cardi b it's ridiculous because it's
also like for me when
people get mad about women that use
their bodies or sex to make money
don't criticize the fact that they're
doing it look at
why is that their only option
here's my problem with cardi b and wop i
haven't really paid attention
but i sure as hell maybe i'm wrong in
this but i think that a lot of
young girls look see that video and they
look up to it yeah and a lot of young
girls go
i get i don't get paid as much as men i
have to work twice as hard to get half
as far so i'll be a stripper
why not just why not like i mean if i'm
20 years old
if that was an option for me when i was
20 years old i would fucking be at dan
bilzerian parties
i would have done that if it was the
only way that i could make fast money
let's like look at the fact that why
is this women's only option why i don't
know because money isn't everything i
mean so okay so this is all
this is the question about what society
i grew up poor i i i
like money but that's
i feel like you like other stuff more
well i
equate money to freedom the freedom to
get i think women look at money
as the ability to leave a bad
relationship that's the ability to be on
your own and not have to
be with someone that is like to me money
was about like
i can surround myself with safe healthy
people because i can rely on myself
i think that's well put just freedom
money i grew up my mom dated for money
she had to that was in uh you know that
generation of women that was sort of
was your business finding someone who
could support you and then putting up
with
their behavior because what choice you
didn't have the option to leave so i
think for a lot of women
money means the option to leave and to
be physically
and mentally safe and so
that's why when people go after like
gold diggers and stuff i just i don't
know i tend to
play angel's advocate on that one wow
very nice
i still i would advocate i wish cardi b
would advocate being a stripper
as you work on your phd or getting
physics or something
but why i just think okay so the
societies can
idolize certain groups of people you can
idolize athletes you can
add a lot idolize actors and actresses
you can
idolize scientists or
people who make a lot of money and i
just think
that a society that's healthier looks up
to
people that are like that seek knowledge
that seek creation not just knowledge
but the creation of beautiful or the
creation of beauty
now you can argue you watch the wab
video it's pretty beautiful
there's a lot of beauty in that video
yeah
yeah but and the physics of it i don't
think anyone can explain it
there's a lot of figuring that's true it
defies gravity requires phd to study
i think she knows a lot more about
physics than you guys do
i take it all back no but like there's
there's different definitions of beauty
and
i you know i think the sexualization
listen i'm a fan of it in some sense i
think it is
it's you know sex is awesome it's gonna
get clipped out
it's honolulu but
the you know i i just think there's
extremes
i don't know i i don't want to overstate
stuff but i i wish there was more
scientists that
young girls and boys would look up to
why are there so few women in
ai and robotics i mean why do only
robots make robots
is my voice not exciting to you no i
love your voice it's incredibly hypnotic
and soothing
all right big fan a lot of people write
to me that they fall asleep to my voice
i just look so perfect you're like
i don't even need ambien anymore i just
well it's very
mono tone is that the word yeah monotone
monotone
i don't know why no one falls asleep to
my voice
that's true i wake up to it
like i told you that pop-up bop's gotten
out of hand we need to
uh it's now in your merch it is you have
a couple like that right mm-hmm shirts
yeah
uh i already forgot what we were saying
the
voices and waking up and wop
no well i think i was asking you
about um definitions of love
no no but you haven't answered that
you've been avoiding it
been evasive yeah no okay let's go there
okay what's the definition of love
i think we already started to talk about
it in terms of relationships
like enjoying
the being that is another human like
just enjoying them fully
understanding them just like
appreciating the the beautiful aspects
of another human being
that's to me is an essential part of
like
forming a connection with them that's
love being excited
them being them so that sounds like
radical acceptance to me
but is it radical acceptance that's sort
of like
you know i think to me love used to mean
i love you now let's get to work and
let's
let's no sexy does sex feel like work to
you
so lex is a top fyi to all the girls
that are
currently composing their dna
[Laughter]
no but like i've listened to you talk
about love a lot on various podcasts
and i'm not saying our definition is
different but i think it's taken me a
long time
to maybe think about it in a way that's
less
dramatic and romantic and
like work like not work but just like
not putting the other person on a
pedestal and not having like such high
expectations
over like what they need to provide like
i feel like love and and i think we
conflate love and passion and
and infatuation and obsession and i
think it took me a long time to realize
that obsession infatuation that is not
you know love i think love should be
sustainable and like kind of boring
like it should energize you not deplete
you uh
it shouldn't be exhausting like we've
all been in those relationships where
you're like up till four in the morning
and talking and
it's like that to me is um
you know i love the flow bear quote i
think i'm i just sort of said that
really fast in case i'm mispronouncing
it
uh you know french b yeah is that it was
that right flow bear that's pretty good
um be what is it like be
calm in your private life so you can be
violent in your personal life
i think there's something to be said for
something that's kind of boring
for lack of a better word because that
just means you're secure and you're not
being adrenalized and you're not
fighting and you're not chasing and
you're not
questioning and and oscillating and
you know perseverating i'm just saying
every synonym uh to sound smart
in front of likes for sure but
you're referring to the practical like
how do we make this thing work
like uh sustainable sustainable yeah
it's good but
there's also just sorry can i say it yep
sorry i don't have a jamie
to pull up quotes uh for me be regular
and orderly
in your life
uh so that you can be violent and
original in your work violent and
original like people like
i don't know in your field but people
like will ferrell and steve carell
they've been married for 30 years and
are in these very stable
kind of relationships so you don't go
home to chaos you don't go home to
over stimulation so that you can yeah
there's all kinds of flavors of
love but i feel like you want like a
passionate like
well it's pussy like it definitely
passion but it doesn't have to be work
yeah like you're like conversations into
four
no i just enjoy like you know i'm a fan
of yours
and that's the beginning of love right
being a fan of someone like i kind of
love joe rogan
because i'm a fan you know i love him as
a human being yeah i'm a fan of
everybody most people in my life i would
say i'm a fan of
and like i enjoy i can literally just
you know i
i enjoy the little quirks like you pick
the good parts and you enjoy them
yeah that that to me like the you know
yes
of course day to day it shouldn't be
like
stressful to to be like you shouldn't
have to put on a face you shouldn't
you know you could be real with them all
that kind of stuff but there should be a
source of like
like the the little quirks is the thing
that like makes your life worth
well if you're in love with someone
flaws or quirks they're charming and
they're endearing
yeah it's that's the stuff that makes it
like awesome
yeah you know that's what makes you miss
them and
look forward to seeing them all that
that kind of stuff but i also think
there's something to be said for i
remember my friend
jane i was talking to her about this guy
that
that you know she had gone through a
divorce and she's like i found the guy
and i'm like how did you know how do you
know
like how do you know this is a guy we
all think this is the girl or this is
the guy or we think we're in love and
she goes
when i'm not with him i don't think
about him
and i thought that was so interesting
she of course thinks about him but she's
not like worrying about him or obsessing
about him or
it's like i can live my life and be in a
relationship with him without it being a
distraction or preoccupation
we can kind of co-exist in an
interdependent way
instead of a codependent way like i can
be the best version of myself when i'm
not around
not with him or and i think that's big
it's taking me a long time to go like
okay love might not be about do i love
the other person and all that we put it
so much on the other person
who am i when i'm with this person do i
i think that
we're in love with someone when we sound
so
um corny but when we love ourselves
to the max in the relationship with the
other person
yeah i'm behaving optimally i'm not
being
uh micromanagey i'm not mothering i'm
not martyring i'm not caretaking i'm not
obsessing i'm not manipulating
because you make me feel secure yeah but
this word codependency you've written
talked about a lot here we go here we
this is one thing i do know
you might be smarter than me in every
other area
in life but like
do you think there's a a beautiful
aspect to
i don't know what the dependency to
to to looking forward not necessarily
thinking about the person but looking
forward to sharing
like the little successes you have in
life to like
like depending on the not the approval
of them but like
looking forward to sharing the successes
but it depends on the motives
so it's like that the difference between
codependence and
interdependence is just motive so like i
can pick you up from the airport
if i just want to be of service and i
want to see you and i get a lot out of
it
if i'm picking you up from the airport
because i feel obligated to i feel
guilty i feel like i have to you're not
gonna like me if i don't that's when
we're in codependence so you can do
ostensibly codependent behaviors
if as long as your motives are what we
say clean as long as i'm not keeping
score
right so it's like um you know and i
think it's just about not
trying to chase or trap or emotionally
entrench you know i think every day
you're with a person it should be a
choice not an obligation
i wake up and i think that to me is the
sexiest kind of love is every day i
choose you
you don't have my hooks in me i don't
have my hooks in you we haven't trauma
bond you don't
uh feel pity or sympathy that's my
nightmare is to be in a relationship
with someone and they feel
guilt or like they have to be with me or
pity which is part of the reason
i've started in in dating people i don't
share a lot about traumas or anything
bad that's happened to me too
soon because i don't want them to feel
sorry for me i don't want
that to be why they stay yeah
i mean it feels like there's stuff you
have to
i guess i don't have any of those
particular demons like i'm i already
have always loved myself like
you have i mean that's why i'm an
inspiration to a lot of people as you've
worked through
some stuff i i don't
i don't know i i'm i'm happy alone i'm
very i love myself but you say you get
lonely
but what i what i mean by that is
it's even more fulfilling to connect
with another human being but like i
i'm okay being by myself yeah me too but
like
i mean can you say lonely and not
needing
like if you're a lone wolf i think to me
nothing's more lonely
than being with someone that doesn't
understand you exactly i'm so much more
lonely when i'm a group in a group of 30
people that i feel like are not in the
same wavelength as me
i don't feel lonely when i'm alone i
feel lonely when i'm with
someone that doesn't understand me or
doesn't see me or that i
don't want to be around yeah and that
that's what
we were talking about dogs a little bit
the fact that you don't have a dog is a
red flag girls ladies interesting fyi
single dudes have to have flags us
dogs i think it's odd when someone
doesn't have an animal
i think we're animal we're designed we
should be with animals i think if you
have the resources to have an animal i
think it's odd to not have one
i think it's masochistic yeah i could
see that because
then it's like a little bit of american
psycho like
yeah he didn't have a dog yeah that's
interesting he probably
he killed it i don't know like why
wouldn't you have a dog you like to
deprive yourself
no i mean uh because if you can't have
it if you think you're ready for a
girlfriend and
you're not ready for a dog i feel like a
woman
please cancel me honestly i try to get
canceled every episode of this podcast
and for some reason it's just not taking
um i just if a guy doesn't have a dog
i'm like
my brain right or wrong i'm just gonna
be honest like
you know maybe it's my self-preservation
instincts or my fear whatever i'm like
okay
afraid of commitment not consistent
like why wouldn't you have a dog yeah no
i love
dogs i used to have you don't want to be
near one ever
no i have a newfoundland which is like
these giant i love giant dogs
i love all dogs newfoundland are these
like huge
like it's a mine was 220 pounds whoa
what was his name oh god they're
gorgeous
black black oh wow they're like bears
yeah named name homer homer
after homer simpson because he was
clumsy and all this is
a photo of a baby next to a newfoundland
and my ovaries are exploding
i just got pregnant is that a good thing
oh yeah in a good way
there's a good point okay no they're
they're they're getting wappy they're
getting whopped up right now
they're getting whipped yeah um
like cuteness yeah i but there's um
it is a commitment and
there's there's something i always
valued now
you get older too which sucks but like i
i still see myself as like a little kid
but we're all just little kids right
yeah we are just
yeah that's the funny thing we're all
the same people i think that's what
always what i do when
um now when someone is yelling or angry
i just picture them as a five-year-old
like having a tantrum and it makes me
stop getting defensive
because we're all just five and in suits
and fancy clothes
it all makes sense yeah but everything
makes sense i just feel like
i want to um i really do want to bring
more
love to the world and it feels like i
have the skill set to build the kind of
technology that can do it and i don't
want
like i'm actually looking for a home now
like like a place to
really i feel like i haven't been in a
home yet you know like like a base
from which you can like yeah get some
shit done yeah and then you could have a
dog
i i feel like i was trying to
maybe it's me running from commitment or
i don't know i don't know what it is but
i felt like i always want to be able to
in a single day just leave everything
behind like i left
literally literally all the girls that
were dming you just deleted their team
i just want to be able to get up and
leave at any moment and have no
attachments at all
that's called a red flag
[Laughter]
i'm not be eloquent about it because i
think humans come along on the journey
and i just that idea of stability
was never that important to me i i
thought like life could be joyful with
the people
close to you you should never be
burdened
by like you know having a house
or having possessions like the people
people matter
like to me people's is the most
important thing by far material
possessions
it's interesting nice but to get in the
way and dogs
interesting see i and maybe this is just
my shit and i need to work on it like
to me people are so unpredictable and
mercurial
that you can't rely on people all you
can rely on are the inanimate objects
like your home in your car
and you're having money in the bank and
that's real stability because humans are
too flawed says the princess in the
castle with the tesla with the moat
don't get me started on the tesla you
don't don't bring this up
don't bring number you know i have
thoughts on the tesla you know i have
issues
i just cannot we could cut this out no
good i just
feel like it's taken me almost two hours
to get into a rant
i just feel like there needs to be more
women in these i don't this has become
such a man woman podcast this is so
vintage whitney but
i just feel like there need to be either
more women or more
sensitive men with kids in these rooms
building
teslas and robots and stuff because
i just feel like no one like a lot of
there's not a woman's touch to the
design of a tesla
to yes thank you but see every time you
tell that to me
you you weren't the second time it's
done this twice
you're already sick of me i'll just
count are we fighting yes
are you mad at me what are you thinking
um i just here's my deal with like for
all of these cars can you
everyone can you plea i mean you're the
person i should be talking to
so i just feel like these little um
what's it called a love a
fob yeah a fob the little mini car
it's a minion yeah yeah okay key fob a
key fob right okay
it's literally a toy car it's a little
and there's no key chain on it it's made
for people
that we have purses and you put it in
and you lose it
and now i'm reaching around my purse
trying to find my little key fob my
little toy car
and then i'm stabbing myself with
pencils and getting tetanus from all the
shit in my purse
and on the way the car you're being
attacked by all kinds of well there's
that
i'm very attractive
i look amazing in these pants how do you
even move about the world you wouldn't
be an
idiot not to want to attack me i turned
sane men into rapists
no but like the little fob like where
where do you keep
where would you it's not purse friendly
it's not purse friendly
and it's like i guess you put in your
pocket but women we work so hard to not
have lumps
like we wear thongs so that you don't
see a panty line and now you want me to
put a little toy car in my pocket
song friendly yes now i look like i have
like a weird tumor or something now it
ruins the whole look
and then i walk to my car and the door
won't open
because it's in my freaking purse and
the
connection is not working can you please
help me out on the words no for sure
i'll i'll
i'll write to you and then elon call me
i mean
i love alan trust me when you and grimes
fall apart
you can you can message grime fall apart
oh there you go i don't know maybe
that's
great when you fall apart you fall
together whatever it is um
oh that's poetry and he and then
i went i went to visit tim dillon in
palm springs and then
it died right and i'm like fine i'm
gonna go charge my tesla
at two in the morning in like a parking
struck
lot and just me alone in the dark women
don't and don't have great associations
with parking lots at night
you know you've brought this up to me
many times once
once who knew in this relationship i'm
the math person
uh hundreds of times and i actually
i didn't i didn't understand what you're
saying
is this like is this like charlie brown
when i talk it's just like
what i'm glad you know i i'm glad you're
saying it on a podcast because then
maybe people can explain it to me so i'm
just not making sense i just my thing is
that the tesla can
fart but it can't open
if a woman has the key in the park
there's some experience listen i'm a
huge fan of creating an experience
that's like
easy natural for all the things you want
to do there's nothing in my experience
that involves
a thong and i i can't even
or if you go on a date with a girl that
i think you just need to
this is this is where i think you lost
me
this is where dating people that you
might not marry come in handy for
someone that's the future of
ai for someone that's the future of
robots like like i say
for me i i do things that i don't want
to do sometimes because i know that as
an artist for art to imitate life i have
to have a life
right and for you to solve the problems
of the average person you have to know
what the life of the average person is
so so you might have to hang out with
some
people so that you know to the to-do
list
so that you know you need to integrate
do you know what i mean schedule
yeah just so you know what problems
you're solving 100 i just didn't
i can't exactly visualize the problem
you have with the key fob and the
fumbling and the purse
like the dynamics of the stuff inside
them are you one of those people with a
million things in the purse
kind of yeah well i'm a woman i have to
have tampons and mace
and water and birth control and you know
i have to have a pharmacy in my purse at
all times so there's something about
that
concealer i mean yeah so yeah well i'll
i look forward to uh maybe grimes can
she she follows me
and we'll post this clip we'll post this
clip
but she seems like she has some notes
for him she seems like she's not afraid
to
challenge him on stuff she seems like on
twitter
yeah damn i mean i love her
but it's just it's i do think that you
know i just i worry
that not having enough women at least
just hanging out in the office
in with you guys 100 percent like i've
seen it's gonna limit the technology
yeah even the idea that pockets
like women don't have don't always have
pockets
is a novel concept to engineers like i
didn't even think about that i mean
we're designed with a pocket
but we don't want to put our key fob in
it i'm just fascinated and this is just
my point of view when i look at new
technology and i'm just like
were no women there in the making of
that
yeah i i'm curious to actually hear what
people say
because i actually think things are it's
it's like the same way that
i feel like the add to cart like that
feature
was made by porn sex drove the internet
right that porn uh is what caught um
there who developed add to cart like
e-commerce yeah e-commerce like japan
like
sexy sex drove it yeah al gore did not
invent the internet
porn didn't believe it or not porn kind
of wait can you uh do
are you just saying things the shopping
cart literally
literally add to cart was like a porn
company
porn to cart and when you used to buy
porn they're used porn used to cost
money
the only thing hotter than watching porn
is paying for porn
there's something kinky about it who
there's a comedian named dan mintz
uh who is one of my favorite jokes on
the planet and he's um
he's very dead pan like very steven
wright mitch hedberg type
and he used to have this joke uh i'm
gonna butcher his delivery but he goes
um
you know with the internet it's
completely changed how
you know we watch porn like before the
internet
i used to have to like wait for the
sears catalog and like turn to the
lingerie
section but now with the internet i can
just go to sears.com
such a great joke um but yeah i just
think i think like
as someone who is about to i think
you're about to make the
thing that's going to change the world
in the most dramatic way maybe in the
history of
humanity and i'm not being dramatic i
hope so
like let's let some of us
like have a girl get a girl to kind of
like be like well what about this thing
and you'll go away
and i think that you know
yeah but that'll help one of the things
especially if it's emotional
everything's driven it's emotional
well you know that's where we shine
generalizations because totally i am so
sexist on this podcast
this is great this is the most sexist
podcast i've ever done
well say uh you know i'm into emotions
as well
you know
and i worry about like just being out of
touch on on this dimension
and many other dimensions like what with
money with power
just not having a good sense of like
design not having a good sense of
like what the experience that most
people have and getting a true diversity
like real diversity of backgrounds
of world views all that kind of stuff
into the design process is
definitely essential i just think that
whatever you're saying about the key fob
thing
is is like ridiculous
[Laughter]
but we also need the the crazy
ridiculous demographic you also
need to go on a date with a girl and see
her fumbling with her purse you don't
believe me you're not
dating is holding you back that's why
you think it's ridiculous
i could also just buy a purse myself i'm
going to show you my purse after this
and then you're going to get a fanny
pack it's kind of like a purse
that's my brand ridiculous rogan makes
the best fanny packs
yeah oh yeah he sells them though oh
they're the best they are at first i was
like
how much better can it's a fanny pack
and you put it on and it just like hugs
your body
yeah it's the best yeah yeah so that's
kind of like a purse
but he probably just like one knife in
there
just one elk eyeball just like some
loins
he's big on tesla he he gets so i don't
think i'm allowed to talk about this but
so we're working on merch
that's like a face oil like i lube my
face up
constantly with oil that's why i'm so
shiny all the time
and it's my thing i love it
and benton has convinced me to
make an oil of all the oils that i use
because i use like six different oils
and we're gonna put it into one oil
right that's awesome and we're gonna
because everyone always asks me what i
put on my face and i'm always so
insecure about my skin
my whole life which is why i've
developed this regimen
hold on my dog's eating a toy and it's
gonna be distracting
so i finally surrendered
and we're gonna release the formula that
i use
and i love really clean packaging like i
just like
clean minimalist minimalist so
minimalist like there's this brand
called labo that does these candles and
it almost just looks like
the tester it's like it's like printed
out like typewriter
and it's just black and white and clear
almost like a
1800s apoca theory type like that's what
i like
i want very simple and minimalist
because i'm already embarrassed to be
doing merch because who do i think i am
and the imposter syndrome has set in
uh i said your merch doesn't it's almost
like a clothing line because it doesn't
have like your face or it doesn't have
any
whitney it's very um it's
you know yeah it's i mean whitney is not
in it
it's uh it's cool it's like a clothing
line benton does all i i have too much
shame to do any of it
like i why who do i think i am what am i
a merch lord now what am i into fashion
like i just there's some comedian like
how dare you like i have so much of that
shit come up
but then yes benton i was like well why
can't we just send the bottle he's like
no it has to be presented so there it's
going to be in a box that has a little
magnetic flap and then you open it and
he's like you have to give people that
moment it has to be christmas morning oh
the guest smart
he talks all about the emotional impact
of something it's all emotional
yeah that's awesome that's beautiful but
and then then you have to decide
and then because i i have to i've been
i've been doing a bunch of design and
the engineering side
it's been uh it's been tricky because
i'm trying to find the right people to
brainstorm with
because i don't know benton no well you
can have that
for like an hour disagree i'll if if i'm
without him he'll i'll starve to death
you can't him for too long yeah you
can't for too long i think i can handle
bending yeah no you can i think you can
i think
if you you have to just be ready for the
truth
with benton like he's just it's
it's how i feel about benton is directly
correlated to how i feel about myself
and i think
because he's just a mirror yeah he will
just say the truth and sometimes i'm not
prepared for it
no i feel like i could you're like uh
you're the daenerys with the dragons
and benton is the dragon
[Laughter]
i'm good with the uh it's good the key
to you i think in your
ascent is like surrounding yourself with
people that don't just agree with you
oh 100 i think that's the death of all
great artists inventors i've seen
so many people demise because they cut
out the people that stood up to them
yeah like i said like relationship wise
that when friends i always
look it's especially now like mit people
started saying oh that guy's smart
or whatever or not with a little bit of
celebrity people are like
they start to idolize you a little bit
so my big
test is like if you message me uh it's
like how good is the person at making
fun of me essentially you're like not
taking me seriously
like i i want people not to take me
seriously or be able to
bring me down a notch because i have a
giant ego
which is i think why you like comedians
so much because i was thinking about how
much you love comedians and i think it's
because
comedians i'm sure non-comedians can do
this but
why would you have access to them you
know it's like we have the ability to
rib each other
without disrespecting each other like
it's actually coming from a place of
respect that's
that's why i miss the roast so much even
though i'm sure they're canceled forever
because they were just
so sexist and racist like it's crazy the
shit we used to say on those
but it started in the friars club as
a form of celebrating each other a form
of you know
it it came from love you know now
ribbing each other is like abuse now or
something
it's it's yeah to be fair those roasts
you guys go deep i i those are hard to
watch sometimes
but that's the idea it's kind of
performance art it's supposed to be like
it's like watching
mma fighters it's supposed to make you
recoil and wince and
and show you where your line is and show
you
i mean that's that's i mean that's with
michael malus that's where
i have a bit of a disagreement where
it's you can also cross the line right
with like trolling that's their ideas
like
we you know the the beautiful version of
trolling is where you me
you you know make fun of each other or
make fun of the powerful
ultimately with a kind of respect or at
least a human
like acknowledging the common humanity
and just having love underneath it
but it's too easy for that to become a
drug to where you just
enjoy taking people down if you're
sadistic
it depends on the motives if i'm like i
can make fun of you and make you laugh
and it's endearing and i'm just trying
to connect with you and make you like me
it's like tickling someone you know what
i mean it's like the emotional version
of the non-physical version of that but
if you're doing it to try to hurt the
person and you're driving pleasure
you're that's sadistic
that's different and it also has to be a
fair fight that's the key to the roast
always the roast was always like
we're gonna rib each other but the
person we're making fun of is gonna go
up and destroy everyone so joan rivers
like the first one i ever did
i knew i could go hard with her because
i knew she was going to fucking kill me
at the end because it was a fair fight
like i literally said my first joke
about joan was
joan i loved you and the wrestler it's a
rough
joke it's like i don't think there's a
rougher thing you can say to another
human being
and then she just came up and i felt no
guilt
it didn't feel bad no one was mad no one
was like ooh because they knew she was
gonna destroy me
so you have to pick on someone your own
size and i think michael malus i don't
know him that well i did just get his
book after listening to your podcast
like i'm not sure he's always picking on
someone his own size
right yeah he he can take it too far but
that's the criticism but he's also in
the political space
where the people are getting way too
powerful so
it's almost like you want to be a little
bit rough to take people down so there's
an argument to be made there but that's
different
yeah we're talking for personal
relationships you want to be a little
bit on the next you want someone that's
gonna
make fun of you a little bit yeah and in
business too like
it's hard though because you're so it's
very hard to
you're not taking seriously you're a
very impressive person
it's not just the impressive so you
don't know the full like
i'm different a lot of people are
intimidated borderline scared of me yeah
i believe that you also walk like a
panther
like elegant and uh and and uh
sexy like yes you also move in a way
that's
very you move like a ninja walking on
the ceiling like
spider-man you move like spider like
you're very not a spider-man with a
tight costume i don't know okay sorry
okay
i don't know you know what i mean i'm
just trying to like you move in a very
predatory
quiet way and you don't emanate
a lot of insecurities whether that's
you just well that's part of the reason
i tried to
say i'm scared and i tried to soften
myself i
i and i've noticed you're not none of
those things
fuck i fell for it too i totally fell
for it
but i do i've noticed especially in my
private life i don't get angry but
in business i do get angry and i i
notice
people get very which is good they
should be scared
at times but i also need like most
people should be scared
but i need to have a circle of people
who are close to me that
like put me in check there's also a
that's really
healthy and smart um there's also a you
make me realize how terrifying silence
is
like you
use silence to your advantage whether
it's intentional or not
i'm just saying do you see what how
anxious i get
like if someone's just being silent it's
such a power move like i just think this
is an important
tool that people can use in any of their
relationships like not engaging
not responding not emailing back is
sometimes the most effective
way to communicate and just let them
whip themselves into a frenzy with
projecting onto that silence and filling
in the blanks with their insecurities
and
as one lady once yelled at me at the
comedy store at two in the morning
when i was on stage in a relationship
with someone that
like a guy that had like it wasn't going
well and i didn't know if i should text
him back and i i was literally asking
the crowd for advice at two in the
morning it was like just the crazy days
of the comedy store
i was like you guys should i text this i
just texted him and he didn't and this
woman just yelled
silence is the only language men
understand
wow it's deep i am a little bit tempted
to just be quiet and see what you do
don't because well i do have to pee so
what i would do is i'd probably just get
up and pee
but i feel like well i feel like i have
to let you get back to like running the
world at some point
so this
is packaging that i would never do
myself
this is for something called eyeliner
this
is packaging that i love very simple
very clean
i'm just saying yeah i know what would
you pick i'd pick
i picked that one the simple clean one
yeah but you know
i don't know i don't know with oils and
makeup and that kind of stuff
i don't know what the right it's a
different discussion that's why i didn't
want to
it's a different discussion of
technology versus makeup sorry i
now have my eye makeup that is blue is
running and i look like i have two black
eyes it looks like you
hit me after i challenged you because i
was crying you made me cry about my dad
yeah how are you doing i'm doing great
how did this go this is fun
did you have a good time yeah i don't
believe you
i did i totally did i don't believe you
so he's i mean oh yeah this is this is
easy it's been a rough
like a few weeks so why just
you haven't been sleeping yeah it's just
crazy amounts of work so
this was like sorry from this was fun
what do you say what do you mean you're
fast this is i i i think this went great
am i wrong you weren't great i think
it's going great i could talk to you all
day
yeah but you don't have time for that
nope i really love the
like i love the wood you can have this
table we're switching it out can i
okay i'm not even kidding we're
switching it out because i don't like
how
cumbersome it's just too big you know
what i find appealing about this table
what is like having it it's like i get
to move it
i like one of my favorite things is to
move heavy objects
i don't know why i have some work for
you
can you carry me to the bed to take a
nap
yeah yeah you were betting said you're
in that person
oh love it me too i have to oh that's
interesting
well for me it's about my
schedule and working at night what i
realized is doing stand-up at night
the best thing i can do is break my days
into two days because i can't wake up at
8am
and then leave the house at 8pm to go to
stand-up so i'll break
my day into two days and i'll take a nap
at like 4 35
and then wake up at seven and i'm like
ready to go to work and then i'll go to
stand up that's kind of a little bit
scheduled
it's a little bit scheduled and uh i've
tried to just keep doing it so that i
stay in whatever my circadian rhythm is
so that i
when i go back on the road which i just
did i wasn't completely out of whack
yeah by the way i got an email saying
that your
tickets to go see whitney cummings from
you know may 2020 whatever
got rescheduled to i they still i
thought they would cancel it or
something which will for what city
uh boston i got i'm going to cape cod
on wednesday thursday nobody said it got
rescheduled to 2020 the wilbur yeah all
of the big
uh the whole tour got pushed to fall
2021. yeah
so i went of course were you gonna come
yeah yeah really i've never seen you do
comedy actually
i mean like live huh i was gonna do that
at comedy store
but uh i made up some sort of excuse
yeah weren't you going to come and you
didn't come i came so i wrote i saw
everybody all the grades of comedy
except whitney comics what was i not
there or you just left when you heard no
you you said
no you actually yeah you weren't there
and i feel like i remember this
you texted me like i was uh what did i
say
i was trying to like trick you into like
helping me get into the comedy story i
think
but then rogan said i'll i'll just let
you in what do you mean you're trying to
trick me i remember why i was texting
you
no i thought like are you going to be
the because it was a bunch of surprise
guests so it didn't say like who
you want to know who i was i wanted to
see if you're one of them and then
you said no but something because was it
after i did your podcast
yeah no i was very intimidated to your
podcast that was
that was awesome i got really scared i
remember there was like one moment where
i got like
really really jumbled and turned around
and i blacked out and i remember going
ugh
you asked me about like animals or
something and i like really panicked
i was like don't be too much because
it's such a it was such an emotional
answer and i was like
you're talking to a quote-unquote
scientist don't be emotional he's not
going to respect you and i got really in
my head
no i i love i respect emotion in fact i
respect them
that's your that's your dating app bio i
respect emotions that'll pull
a lot of ladies i hear you i understand
you i respect your emotions
swipe right yeah no it'd be a long time
for go
if i go with the dating app i don't know
i don't know about this world but i do
you'll say very wistful things
just really casually under your breath
you're like anyway so
i love life
[Laughter]
you'll say really profound things really
casually yeah
it's a good reminder that's your
you should do merch i love life life is
great now
like one worry i have
is when i talk about like love a lot i
i worry that i don't want it to be like
a brand or something
you know like it's it's both is
basically me being high from
pulling all nighters and just
you know it's amazing to me that someone
is such a high performance like
fasting and chicken and ground beef
and what are they called fucking
athletic greens that like
and you don't sleep yeah
i'm not gonna get into it okay i'm not
so i listen to my body
good boundary no i'm not gonna get into
the
there it's so popular now to emphasize
sleep
the science on sleep in the book that
david
hot take is you don't need eight hours
well that by the way is not the
the the the book that people
talk about with sleep with rogan those
conversations that book has a lot of
questionable science in it
i'm blanking on the guy's name no yeah i
know what you're talking about
but so there's actually people should
check out you'll probably
whoever is listening to this before see
it's still even recording
we are recording right did we record any
of that
did we just go on a date yeah this is if
it's not being recorded we're on a date
i keep i keep forgetting this camera
once again yeah i the
people should check out the blogs
written about it that show that much of
the evidence
in that book is on very shady ground
that said
i think it's not controversial to say
that sleep is probably important but
it's not it's
the kind of sleep you're getting right
yeah the kind of sleep and also like
really important the same thing with
diet and sleep is like understand
yourself
yeah yeah yeah what do you need what do
you need and also how like how it fits
i i'm a huge believer that like it's not
about the sleep it's about
like reducing the stress in your life so
whatever the hell like
the reason i don't sleep isn't because
like i'm on like a drug binge or like
some crazy stuff it's because i do what
i love you know you don't want to go to
sleep
yeah i don't want to go to sleep and so
you know
yeah and then people that criticize me
like lex you look tired you should get
more sleep and they're like they're
going
whoever says that blocked them that's
not no they
hate that shit but it's like a motherly
thing too like people want you know
i'm worried about you looks like there's
a lot of people like worried about me
i get it i understand that instinct but
like i
i'm doing what i love don't don't you
know
it's uh if you don't get enough sleep it
is what it is like
not be less worried about you really
interesting you know i think you're the
smartest one of the smartest people
alive i think whatever
decisions you know yeah i think i'm not
gonna give you notes on how to
live well so sometimes people are
intelligent in like in weird ways but i
definitely
also stop slowing down the tech progress
telling you to sleep means we're gonna
get robots later okay
if i were to actually the thing i love
hearing
is is like go harder it's like
you sleep way too much as far as i'm
concerned no
for real though i mean i i don't know
everyone is different i'm more of the
david gaga's variety like i love hearing
like
stop being a little weak bitch and work
harder i love that
you know that that means they really
care about the they
people understand that i'm doing i think
your dad did a great job
i think your dad nailed it yeah um all
right so the lex
you've changed the name of your podcast
just your name yeah but it
gives me the freedom to uh like it
started
with you basically i mean i don't have
to talk to people that are
exclusively ai people no that's what i
kind of realized no and then after you
you were the gateway drug to like
to talk to people that knew nothing
about ai and just pretended they did
like stephen codkin talked about stalin
and yeah
yeah these conversations just like go
deep on stuff that
only tangentially releases yeah well i
just think it's important because like
the people that are making rope the
robots are going to be
a reflection of the people that make
them yeah and i hope
that people like you are
exposing themselves to more things than
just ai so that the ai
doesn't isn't just the robots aren't
robotic if that makes any sense
yeah so that eventually if we think big
enough we'll fix the tesla
key fob that's going to get me in so
much trouble is this going to get me in
trouble for saying that i don't know do
we need to cut it out
it's not going to get you in trouble
it's a totally interesting criticism i
think you're
you're spot on and it's amusing it's not
a criticism it's amusing
it's amusing it's an amusing musing i'm
known for my hot takes
it's not even that hot it's like one
take it's a lukewarm take
well as you said it's ridiculous yeah
it's it's like it's difficult to find
the key fob in the purse
and therefore we need more by the way
it's not just the tesla that does that a
lot of cars have that key fob that's
just supposed to float around i'm sorry
it's the whole thing
right now there's like thousands of
people that will write to me that
whitney was spot on with this so i'm i i
it that's awesome and then maybe you
will get grabbed
like they're stalking me i'm gonna be
like no they're just giving you feedback
yeah the girl dming you that you don't
want to fuck isn't a stalker
it's just a person damning you
they're awfully aggressive for not being
stalkers women are aggressive now
no they're actually okay it's so funny
to watch women that
i mean especially attractive women that
clearly don't
they're not very good at asking people
out which is hilarious well
you're also a weirdo yeah it's important
you get all you hear
all you've high performing scientists
and robot people
it's like you're so literal so
women can't be figurative with you we
have to be literal and then we're too
aggressive
but if we're not aggressive you guys are
like like you don't see it
okay so i'm like hey what's up and
you're like nothing and i'm like all
right well that didn't go anywhere
okay how good of a pickup line is what's
up well you know what i'm saying i'm
flirting
okay you guys aren't great at subtext
but then
hey what's up big fan big fan love your
work
love to get to know you what how can
someone ask you out without being a
stalker
no i don't know i'm i'm joking it's you
are i'm not
you're joking i'm not yeah just being
genuine and real i mean that's the same
thing probably the other side
like you don't have to do pick up lines
but show that you're interesting that
there's like
depth to you as a person but in dms well
how am i how am i going to show you that
if we don't get on the
zoom or or on the students yeah cause
you won't respond because you're being
too literal and you think if i ask you
out i'm a stalker
well the yeah i mean i don't know you're
a celebrity and
i'm sure you get a million messages like
one of the problems i have is the number
of messages
which is why i we should be careful
saying this but like
i really enjoy it when people like stop
me like in an airport
because i'm not yet famous enough to
where like that's a problem
and then i'll have like a real
conversation with them yeah that's cool
yeah but no women so far did that or one
woman did but she was like
my boyfriend is a huge fan of yours oh
yeah that's my thing guys will come up
to me and like my girlfriend loves you
i've never heard of you yeah okay all
right
cool you're so cool they have to hurt
your feelings
yeah guys like hey i look i don't know
who you are but my girlfriend loves you
so can i just take a picture with you
like i don't like you it's like dude
what just
so you like go into their phone and
subscribe to your podcast
that's a really good idea it's just like
good for you
why i think that sometimes the opposite
sex doesn't want to i don't know they
just like probably they need to like
like neg me or something and like hurt
my feelings when they come up to me i
don't get it but my girlfriend's
obsessed with you like i don't know why
do people stop you a lot they stop me a
lot it's really
interesting like i think people
i always say like if you really know me
you know that
you shouldn't because you know that i
get stressed out because i never feel
like i could
have to perform well no i just don't
think i can deliver you know like i just
it's like
or they manage expectations they'll be
like hey can i get a photo from here and
i'm like yes cool
cause after the initial engagement i
don't know what else to give you
like i've given everything i have
whether it's on podcasts or social media
or whatever like by the time i see you i
just feel like i'm gonna be a
disappointment to you
like there's no way i can ever give you
what you need in this exchange and i
think people that really know me know
that
so the people that really know me will
come and be like hey i know you can't
give me what i need but let's just do it
i'm like yes cool
the silence thing like my strategy is i
just i listen
like i'll i'll just i'll be i'll do i'll
use the silence
to get them to tell me about themselves
and like
i see the joy in their eyes that's
energizing and like really what they
want
is like okay so there's uh they already
probably know you really well
yeah they've actually they're probably
one-way friends with you because they
know the part which is by the way i
i was just in denver when people stop me
on the street or yell out like
it's the best feeling in the world like
that's why i do this like
when celebrities or public figures like
oh people stop me and recognize me it's
like is that what you wanted yeah that's
what i wanted i wanted like someone to
see me and go like oh my god that's when
he comes and gets super excited
it's an awesome feeling it's the best
and guess what like
i work for them yeah they they're my
employer so when people i don't stop and
do photos it's like get the fuck out of
here like they're who
bought your special they're who make you
get paid
like who do you think you are i i will
stand in new photos as long as people
want to take them
and they're like they've been like some
of the coolest people it breaks my heart
a little bit to say goodbye
they say that's the hardest part that's
exactly what i'm talking about is when
someone knows come up to me i'm like i
don't want to
hurt your feelings but i do have to go
like i just get codependent with them
because i want to give so much
and i don't want them to go because i
think even if you talk for a half an
hour to someone as soon as you have to
go it's like well should fucking go
you know but like my favorite it's a on
the
at the the la airport actually this was
my favorite is
i love if you're if you do this to me at
the airport i love this which is like
it was like a urinal i was in the
bathroom and the guy was uh
standing there he's like bro you're alex
friedman
hell yeah and then he just like he
finished and walked away
and then he like smiled and nodded like
there was a kind of
the brevity but everything was said like
with our eyes
yeah i don't know bro it was like bro
okay it's bro talk
yeah it's like we're connected like yeah
i get like whoa
it's windy it's like yeah like it was
the best yeah no it's the best
yeah it's the best and then like we
passed each other again he was like yeah
i love when people know me from rogan
when it's like bros they're like where
are you going trolling shit and they're
like oh yeah and it's like
it's like i love that yeah like i love
when it's like
yeah when it's just that's what else is
there this is what we're here for like
that
is it to me that is like the epitome of
happiness is like
i love what you do you made a difference
in my life
fucking fuck yeah fucking fuck yeah what
the fuck what's better than that it's
the best feeling in the world
when i cannot stand when celebrities
like oh god this person recognized me
it's like oh
you know just who do you we're lucky
yeah or different levels but it's all
the same
we're lucky anything else i end these
very awkwardly
you know that balance
i hate i don't do well with eye contact
at all i'll just start crying
do you like marina bramovic tell me more
about your father oh my god
that was touch and go whoa that could
have been bad and i totally would have
gone further but i wore blue eyeliner
and it's starting to bleed onto my face
and i just look like i've
been hanging out with like turner well i
really enjoyed this
so did i what grade would you give me
11 out of hundreds
just 11.
um we'll do it again let's do it again
in austin maybe
yeah hot take hot damn
literally that's the one the downsides
is it's hot
but rogan is opening the austin comedy
club yep
can't wait so build build a new
i hope to build be part of elon musk is
moving there i hope to be part of
building
a new better silicon valley
tech empire there maybe i can come and
make it silicone valley
oh that's why you're a comedian
that's the worst joke i've ever made
that's what's going to end my career as
a comedian
[Laughter]
you're so quick it's just impressive
that's why you're a professional they
pay you the big bucks
yeah i could see that being the new
place for for comedy for culture yeah
i'd love that maybe i love your podcast
i it's really hard for me to get i'll
like sample podcast
but you the michael episode i love the
david eagleman
episode i loved i'm not gonna listen to
one with your dad
yeah yeah but i i love your podcast
i feel like it makes me smarter go to
the part where i tell him he
he wasn't a good father
i even time stamped it i disagree with
you i think he nailed it
i think saying saying that your parents
are bad parents you're insulting
yourself
you're insulting the product they made
the design
whatever he did was pretty good yeah
but we're in it when we're in it it's
yeah i know
it's rough i mean like radical
forgiveness with my parents i'm like
thank you for fucking me up because it
made me work hard like i'm just in i did
it the other way i did the blame thing
and it just didn't work
so i'm doing like contrary action they
nailed it
thank you for starting to drink at 5 00
pm thank you for forgetting to pick me
up from school
made me resourceful and then you also
give them a pass well back in the
yeah whatever they were all molested
they were molested
yeah there's no instagram however that
connects to
why not defend them defend your parents
at all costs and just see how your life
changes
okay i'll try it out you know what i
always say on this podcast we forgive
others not because they deserve
forgiveness but because we deserve peace
just try forgiving everyone for a week
and just see if your life changes at all
i forgive you what are you wrong
okay just end it there yeah
all right just chop don't ride elephants
love you guys likes friedman this is a
big one you guys
don't say that your stalkers are gonna
think you're talking to them
[Applause]
you